Oh, Jay, did you comb your hair this morning? No, it's still uncompum. I haven't combed my hair since working on Little House in the Prairie, to be honest. 82, 81? 1981, I think it was. Wow. And I'm wearing a hat because you told me that my hair was bad, and I got a haircut, and I didn't want to show you what it was yet.
噢，杰伊，你今天早上梳头了吗？没有，还没梳。老实说，自从拍《草原小屋》以来我就没梳过头了。82年，81年？我想是1981年吧。哇。而且我戴着帽子，因为你跟我说我的发型不好看，我去剪了头发，但我还不想让你看到是什么样。
I didn't say it was bad. I said it was under product. Oh, okay. Very good. Well, you know what's not bad? What? Next episode of Smartless Aircom. Are you feeling better today, Jason?
我没说不好看。我说的是没怎么打理。噢，好吧。很好。嗯，你知道什么不不好吗？什么？下一集的 Smartless Aircom。杰森，你今天感觉好点了吗？
Look at them. Not really. Oh. Doctor figured, you know, since I had COVID. Sure. And then, so the immunity system, whatever it's called? You're still seeing Dr. Figured? Yeah.
看看他们。其实没有。噢。医生觉得，你知道的，既然我得过新冠。当然。然后呢，免疫系统，叫什么来着？你还在看菲格医生？对。
She figured that my systems all run down. And so that's why I got the head cold from Maple right afterwards. I know why I can't lick it. She must have gone to. Sounds like she went to hell of a med school to put that together. Oh, man. yet she can't give me anything to fix it. What about, wow, but maybe it's because you finally calmed down for a sec.
她觉得我的身体状况全面下降。所以这就是为什么我紧接着就被梅普尔传染了重感冒。我懂为什么我好不了。她一定是去过。听起来她好像上了个厉害的医学院才得出这个结论。天呐。然而她什么也给不了我来治好它。话说，哇，但也许是因为你终于安静了一会儿。
Like you were so busy and now it's like, whew, right? Yeah, that could be it. And I do like to do nothing, so. Yeah, it suits you. Yeah. You feel better tomorrow. You feel a little better today, yeah? You sound like shit.
就像你以前太忙了，现在就像是，呼，对吧？对，也许吧。而且我确实喜欢无所事事，所以。对，很适合你。对。你明天会感觉好点。你今天感觉好一点了吗？对？你听起来糟透了。
Yeah, and yeah, how do I, I shouldn't be doing this record. You look great. You always look great. No, you look great. Thank God you had all that surgery, right? All that surgery. covers up you did all that face work yeah this is a great time it's really settling your face is really settled dude I wanted to say that the other day uh do I still look surprised I think I had them I stitched the eyebrows up too high what do you take
对，然后，我怎么，我不该做这个录音。你看起来气色很好。你总是看起来气色很好。不，你看起来气色很好。谢天谢地你做了所有那些手术，对吧？所有那些手术。掩盖了你做过所有的面部微调，对，这是一个很好的时机，真的很自然，你的脸真的很自然，老兄，我前几天就想说这个，呃，我看起来还很惊讶吗？我想我把眉毛缝得太高了，你吃了什么？
Jade what do you take when you feel like that you take yesterday you took Theraflu I used to take that all the time and then they discontinued it no I I got a black market oh you I do I take a I take one of those pseudofeds with all everybody's like well this got all the heavy-duty shit. I'm like, yeah, I want the fucking thing that gets me all. Yeah, you have to ask for it behind the thing, right? They got to fucking unlock it, are you sure you want? I'm like, look, I'm not making meth in my bathtub, man.
杰伊，你感觉不舒服的时候吃什么？你昨天吃了泰诺。我以前经常吃，然后他们停产了。不，我，我买的是黑市的，噢，我吃的是那种含有伪麻黄碱的药，所有人都说，嗯，这里面都是些猛药。我说，对，我就要那种能让我整个人。对，你得去柜台后面要，对吧？他们得把它锁起来，问你确定要吗？我说，听着，我不在浴缸里制毒，老兄。
I'm just trying to get through today. Right. But does it knock you out and make you all sleep? I guess that's not going to sleep. No, it gets you all jazzed up and then you crash and you feel like shit. Yeah. But you kind of get through the day. But it's like, yeah, it's like a shot of prednisone or something.
我只是想熬过今天。对。但它会让你昏昏欲睡吗？我想这不会让人想睡觉。不，它会让你整个人像打了鸡血一样兴奋，然后药效一过你就会崩溃，感觉糟透了。对。但你总算能熬过这一天。但感觉就像，呃，就像打了一针强的松之类的。
What did you guys do last night? Last night, we went to, we went and put the lights up on a tree at our friend house with the kids. Just a very random tree? Just a random way. I go around the neighborhoods. You know what I said to Maple the other day?
你们昨晚做什么了？昨晚，我们去，我们和孩子们一起去朋友家给一棵树装上了灯。只是一棵很随意的树？只是一棵随意的树。我在各个街区转悠。你知道我前几天对梅普尔说什么吗？
She said, you know, you hear all these Christmas because I always have the Christmas music on in the car from Thanksgiving forward. I love that. I love that. And she's like, what about, where do they do Christmas caroling in the world? And I said, well, just in everyone's neighborhood.
她说，你知道的，你听过所有这些圣诞歌，因为我从感恩节开始就在车里一直放圣诞音乐。我太喜欢那个了。我太喜欢了。然后她说，世界上什么地方会报佳音呢？我说，嗯，就在每个人的街区里。
I said, you should do that with your friends. You should just start walking around some neighborhood and you just stop on the sidewalk in front of someone's house. and you just start singing, and the people inside kind of hear it, and they come to the door or the window, and they look, and they're charmed, and they're warmed,
我说，你应该和你的朋友们一起去。你们就随便找个街区走走，然后在别人家门前的马路牙子上停下来。然后你们就开始唱歌，里面的人听到声音，就会走到门边或窗前，看着你们，被你们吸引并感到温暖，
and it's that spirit. And she's like, oh, I'm going to do that. So I think she's going to do that. Next year, it's too late now to learn the songs and everything. What does it mean, learn the songs? They can read them off the book. She knows we wish you a Merry Christmas all that Christmas. Remember, Sean, you used to do that at your house.
这就是那种精神。然后她说，哦，我要去试试。所以我想她会去做的。明年吧，现在学歌和各种东西已经太迟了。什么叫学歌？他们可以照着书读啊。她知道《我们祝你圣诞快乐》所有这些圣诞歌。记住，肖恩，你以前在你家也这么做过。
He used to sit behind the piano. Fuck it, J.B., I would love to see your face when a bunch of people came singing out your door. You'd be like, get the hell out of you. What the fuck? I'd get up my BB gun. I'm trying to watch Jen Sacky right now. You're interrupting Rachel Maddow.
他以前坐在钢琴后面。去你的，杰比，如果有一群人在你门外唱歌，我真想看看你的表情。你大概会说，滚你妈的。搞什么鬼？我会拿气枪出来。我正打算看简·萨基的节目呢。你打断了雷 Rachel Maddow 的节目。
I paused MSNBC for this bullshit. What's going on? I tell you you can sing. Oh, this is, look at the segment. I tell you who can make a lot of music that people would give anything to see them outside their door, including me. I would give almost anything these.
为了这破事我把 MSNBC 暂停了。怎么回事？我跟你说你会唱歌。哦，这个是，看看这个环节。我跟你说谁能做出许多音乐，让人愿意付出一切去看他们在家门外表演，包括我在内。为了这些，我几乎愿意付出一切。
Do they make beautiful music? Our guests today are two, musicians who helped, they really changed the direction of music in my view. And I'm not alone in that, in that. One is a songwriter whose work showed that songs could be everything from melodic to abrasive to emotionally direct. And the other is a guitarist whose approaches can be only described as textured and full of tension and restraint. Never heard you say textured. I know. I'm so, excited. I'm like, I'm like, I'm buzzing a little bit. Yeah, yeah, I'm just
他们能创作出美妙的音乐吗？我们今天的嘉宾是两位音乐人，依我看，他们确实改变了音乐的方向。而且不仅我一个人这么认为。其中一位是词曲作家，他的作品表明歌曲可以包罗万象，从旋律优美到刺耳粗粝，再到情感直接。另一位则是吉他手，他的演奏风格只能用充满质感、张力和克制来形容。从没听过你说“充满质感”。我知道。我太兴奋了。我感觉，我感觉整个人有点飘飘然。对，对，我只是
together, these guys, they created a band whose influence could be heard across decades of music shaping and influencing artists from Nirvana to Radiohead. Jason just fucked up. Every sort of, I think everybody who came after
在一起，这两个家伙，他们组建了一支乐队，其影响力跨越了几十年的音乐历程，塑造和影响了从涅槃乐队到电台司令的音乐人。杰森刚刚搞砸了。每一种，我觉得每一个在他们之后
them had to be influenced by them. Certainly, they've just, their music has just been, their sort of their legend has grown since the moment they started making music. Please welcome, Charles Thompson, also known as Black Francis and Joey Santiago, they are pixies. Oh, wow. Jesus Christ, well, what have you done?
出现的人都不可避免地受到了他们的影响。当然，他们的音乐，他们的传奇色彩从他们开始创作音乐的那一刻起就在不断增长。请欢迎查尔斯·汤普森（又名黑色弗朗西斯）和乔伊·圣地亚哥，他们就是小精灵乐队。噢，哇。天哪，你们都干了些什么？
You guys, good morning, Ben. Wow. Wow, anybody else? Oh, Willie. Guys. Willie. Will, are your pants even on? I hope that's okay.
伙计们，早上好，本。哇。哇，还有其他人吗？噢，威利。伙计们。威利。威利，你的裤子穿好了吗？我希望没问题。
They weren't supposed to know, man. Heck Will's sitting on plastic. This will, oh, this is. Gentlemen, Joey, I heard you sipping your coffee or tea or whatever. whatever you've got. Both of you. Charles, you got one going too. It's fresh. Where are we, first of all, where are we finding you guys today? Let's just start there. Where we are now?
他们本不该知道的，老兄。见鬼，威利正坐在塑料凳上。这个威利，噢，这个是。各位先生，乔伊，我听到你在啜饮咖啡、茶或者随便什么东西。你手里拿的任何东西。你们俩都是。查尔斯，你手里也有一杯。很新鲜。首先我们在哪里，我们今天在哪里连线你们？我们就从这开始吧。我们现在在哪里？
I'm in Los Angeles. Beautiful. Hey, Joe. Do you get home okay? Yeah? Oh, wow. Tell us what happened. I mean, because I'm not in Los Angeles. I'm in Northampton, Massachusetts. But we just, I don't know. I feel like I just got home like last night,
我在洛杉矶。太美了。嘿，乔。你顺利到家了吗？是吗？噢，哇。给我们讲讲发生了什么。我是说，因为我不在洛杉矶。我在马萨诸塞州北安普顿。但我们刚，我不知道。我觉得我好像昨天才到家，
but really, I guess we ended a couple weeks ago, but it took me a couple weeks to get home. You walked. So now, Joey, I just haven't talked to him since the last time we were. You guys haven't talked since you were like, what, doing a show or something? Were you guys on Tijuana? Exactly. Like, we were in Honolulu.
但其实，我想我们几周前就结束了，但我花了好几个星期才到家。你是走回来的。所以现在，乔伊，我自上次我们……你们就一直没联系。你们俩是不是自从在什么蒂华纳演出之后就没说过话了？没错。就像，我们在檀香山。
We were like, oh, I see later. All right. And so it's like, oh, hey, Joe. Where are you? Did you go home? I went home. I mean, it took me two weeks to get here. Anyway, I'm sorry.
我们当时就说，噢，回见啦。好的。然后就像，噢，嘿，乔。你在哪？你回家了吗？我回家了。我是说，我花了两个星期才到那儿。总之，我很抱歉。
No, I like this. I'm self-centered here. Having an offshoot conversation already here. No, Charles, you have to know that you heard us catching up. This is where we catch up with each other too. Exactly. Do your housekeeping right now. Let's get into some admin.
不，我喜欢这样。我在这里挺以自我为中心的。已经开始聊起题外话了。不，查尔斯，你得知道你听到了我们叙旧。这也是我们互相叙旧的地方。没错。现在就处理好你们的日常杂务吧。我们来谈点行政事务。
Joe, how did you got home okay? Yeah, thank God, yeah. I mean, non-stop. If I would have stopped, it would have been the Pacific Ocean. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, yeah. What about, it's an 11-hour flight over there to the way. Massachusetts though, right?
乔，你到家还顺利吗？对，谢天谢地，是的。我是说，直飞。如果我停下来的话，就会掉进太平洋了。对，没错。对，对。话说回来，飞到那边去是一场11个小时的飞行吧？
That's a big trip. With a bunch of other big trips, though, that were right behind it. So it was sort of, I did binge watch. I'm getting very cranky with the media available. I like it when I have, I have to load, I have to download a bunch of YouTube videos to get me through those like 12-hour flights and stuff. And I feel terrible.
但马萨诸塞州，对吧？那是一趟长途旅行。不过紧接着还有好几趟其他长途旅行。所以我基本上是疯狂补剧。我对现有的媒体资源越来越挑剔了。我喜欢，我得提前下载一堆 YouTube 视频来撑过那些12小时左右的飞行之类的。而且我感觉糟透了。
I wish I had more patience. for the films or television programs, but I get all, I don't want to watch this. And then I change it. I don't want to watch this. So then I... What did you binge? What'd you get to?
我真希望自己对电影或电视节目能有更多的耐心。但我一看到就会变得，我不想看这个。然后我就换台。我不想看这个。所以我就……你都狂刷了些什么？你看了什么？
I have so many options. You know, like, I remember, do you remember People's Express Airlines? Sure. Yeah. You could, I think it was like $149. And you paid, didn't you pay, like, when you got on the plane? Yeah. Like, you paid, like, some guy who came down.
我有太多的选择了。你知道的，就像，我还记得，你们还记得人民快运航空吗？当然。对。你可以，我想只要149美元左右。而且你付钱，你不是在上飞机的时候付钱吗？对。就像，你付钱给某个走下来收钱的家伙。
and I remember paying in cash. Yeah. For snacks. For fly to L.A. Oh, wow. And you brought, you could bring a lunch. Everyone brought back a brown bag to lunch. It was, it was, it was an economical way to fly.
我记得我是用现金付的。对。买零食。为了飞去洛杉矶。噢，哇。而且你带了，你可以带午餐。每个人都带了一个牛皮纸袋装午餐。那是一种经济实惠的飞行方式。
I remember, because I grew up in Toronto and you used to do, you could go to New York, so we'd take a bus to Buffalo Airport, and then you could pay, and it was like $100 to fly to New York from Buffalo. There's an airline out there that's proposing you could stand up. And apparently on this airline, you can, you can. roll the windows down too. You can. That's what they said. They fly at a real low altitude. Roll the windows down, relax. You know what I was amazed by? I just learned
我记得，因为我在多伦多长大，你以前可以去纽约，所以我们会坐大巴去布法罗机场，然后你可以付费，从布法罗飞纽约大概只要100美元。现在有家航空公司提议你可以站着坐飞机。显然在这家航空公司里，你还可以。把窗户摇下来。你真的可以。他们是这么说的。他们在很低的高度飞行。摇下窗户，放松一下。你知道让我震惊的是什么吗？我才刚知道
like a year ago, like, you know, when you look at the stats when you're flying, that it's like 70 below zero up there. Wow. Oh, Sean. I didn't know it was that cold outside. Sure, it's really cold when you get up there. Have you ever seen videos of people climbing mountains before? Yeah, but it's not 70. I mean, they're not in Hawaiian shirts most of the time.
大约一年前，你知道的，当你查看飞行数据时，上面显示高空温度是零下70度。哇。噢，肖恩。我不知道外面有那么冷。当然，你飞到高空时真的很冷。你见过人们登山的视频吗？对，但没有零下70度。我是说，他们大部分时间可不穿夏威夷衬衫。
I don't know if you notice that. They're not in Speedos when they're going up Everest, dude. This would have been a good question for us to ask. What was that scientist we had on that I marveled? I really impressed him with my skills, my questions and stuff. Neil de Gras? Yeah, this would have been a good question for him. Since we're closer to the sun, why is it?
我不知道你有没有注意到这一点。老兄，他们登珠峰的时候可不穿紧身三角裤。这本来是个很好的问题可以问我们之前请过的那个科学家，我当时惊艳到了他。我用我的技能、我的问题什么的给他留下了深刻的印象。尼尔·德格拉斯？对，这对他来说是个好问题。既然我们离太阳更近了，为什么会这样？
Listen, we've got pixies on. We're wasting time. We're talking about, guys, this is really cool. Gentlemen, this is really, really cool. So you guys, I love one. people, when great things start from basically chance encounters, if you will. You guys live next door to each other. Is that true?
听着，小精灵乐队还在呢。我们在浪费时间。我们在聊，伙计们，这真的很酷。各位，这真的非常非常酷。所以你们，我喜欢当人们，当伟大的事情基本上始于偶然的相遇时，如果你愿意这么说的话。你们俩曾是邻居。是真的吗？
There's this, well, what's the name of that? That's, that dormitory, Joe, that's... Sylvan? Sylvan. Sylvan. At UMass Amherst, there's like three buildings called Syldin or whatever. So, yeah, I guess they're all Sylvan. Anyway, what do they call those, Joe?
有这么个，嗯，那个叫什么名字？那个宿舍，乔，那是……西尔凡？西尔凡。马萨诸塞大学阿默斯特分校有三栋名为西尔凡还是什么的建筑。所以，对吧，我想它们都叫西尔凡。总之，那些叫什么，乔？
They're... Sweets, right? You have like seven roommates. You know, it's like a suite, you know, and you share. It's kind of like a little, they're like, it's like a cinder block building. It's literally like a, I shouldn't say it's like a prison because I've never been to prison, but it's like kind of like a prison, you know. Like without bars, but it's like, you know, really, you know, rudimentary kind of,
它们是……套间，对吧？你有大约七个室友。你知道的，这就像一个套间，然后你们共用。这有点像一个小小的，它们就像，就像一个煤渣块砌成的建筑。简直就像一个，我本不该说它像监狱，因为我从没进过监狱，但它确实有点像监狱，你知道的。没有铁窗，但非常，你知道的，非常简陋的那种，
there was like a living room and then there's like a three or four bedrooms and then there's a bathroom shower area. And there's about seven of us at a suite, you know. And so we were in the same suite at our freshman year. You just freaked Jason out because he's thinking about the communal shower already. I saw his arms go up. Jason, I mean, you're out. You're gone.
里面有一个起居室，然后有三四个卧室，然后是一个浴室淋浴区。一个套间里大约有七个人，你知道的。所以我们大一的时候就在同一个套间里。你把杰森吓坏了，因为他已经在脑补公共浴室了。我看到他的胳膊抬起来了。杰森，我是说，你已经神游了。你不在状态了。
Yeah, I'm just not going to shower until junior year when I have my own apartment. Wait, so this is at UMass Amherst. And this is what year? is like 84 am I going to say or is it earlier? Something like that, yeah. 83. 83. You guys are sharing this cinderblock suite as Charles, you made it sound so beautiful.
对，我直到大三有了自己的公寓之前都不会洗澡了。等等，这是在马萨诸塞大学阿默斯特分校。那是哪一年？是84年吗，还是更早？差不多吧，对。83年。83年。你们俩合住这个煤渣块套间，正如查尔斯刚才把它形容得那么美好。
And so you guys are in there. And what happens? Who goes, hey, do you want to start a band? Like, I just love this. Charles was playing. You had your acoustic guitar already and you were playing a lot. I had some annoying songs that I would kind of play around the dormitory on a regular basis.
然后你们就在那儿。接下来发生了什么？谁先说，嘿，你想组建一个乐队吗？真的，我太喜欢这个了。查尔斯当时在弹。你当时已经有木吉他了，而且经常弹。我有一些烦人的歌曲，会经常在宿舍里弹来弹去。
And Joey was kind enough to kind of sit in and kind of plunk along. He got his guitar out. And, you know, neither one of us were like, what you call, you know, guitar weenies or whatever, you know, we were like hanging out, playing the guitar all the time. We weren't that, we appreciate the art form,
而乔伊人很好，会坐下来跟着一起乱弹。他拿出了他的吉他。而且，你知道的，我们俩都不是那种所谓的吉他高手什么的，你知道的，我们只是闲晃，整天弹吉他。我们没有那么，我们欣赏这种艺术形式，
but we weren't like, you know, we weren't, we hold into it or anything like that. Were you looking for people to listen? Did you care? I don't know. I think we were pretty like, we didn't know what we wanted. I think that like I remember I worked at the university campus store and, you know, they had the radio on, you know, win tickets tonight, you know.
但我们并没有，你知道的，我们没有对它着迷或者别的什么。你们当时在找人听吗？你们在乎吗？我不知道。我觉得我们挺随意的，我们不知道自己想要什么。我觉得我当时记得我在大学校园书店工作，然后，你知道的，他们开着收音机，今晚赢取门票，你知道的。
I remember it was James Taylor, I think it was, and nothing against James Taylor. But, you know, at that time, that wasn't necessarily at the top of my list. but call now. I called from the back room, and they gave me a pair of tickets. Joe, do you want to go see James Taylor tonight? Okay. You know, it was all kind of like, nothing to do.
我记得那是詹姆斯·泰勒，我想是的，绝对不是对詹姆斯·泰勒有意见。但是，你知道的，在那个时候，那不一定是我愿望清单上的首选。但现在就打电话。我从后室打了电话，他们给了我两张票。乔，你今晚想去看詹姆斯·泰勒吗？好吧。你知道的，这一切都有点像，没事可做。
It was like, okay, let's do that. And like even when we started being a band dealing with like record company types, they would make a suggestion and we would say like, okay, you know, because we were just, we didn't really know how anything worked. And so it was all good. It was like, it was action.
就像，好吧，那就这么办吧。甚至在我们开始作为乐队与唱片公司的人打交道时，他们会提出建议，而我们会说，好吧，你知道的，因为我们只是，我们真的不知道任何事情是怎么运作的。所以一切都很好。就像，这是一种行动。
It was something that was going to happen, you know. So anyway, I kind of lost my point there. No, no, no, no. You're right on point. And I was going to say, so you guys, you're there. You're kind of, you're playing, for lack of a better term, jamming as, as, as dumb as that sound. Yeah. But you are.
这是将会发生的事情，你知道的。所以无论如何，我刚才有点跑题了。不，不，不，不。你切中要害了。我本想说，所以你们俩，你们在那儿。你们有点像是在，为了找不到更好的词来形容，在即兴演奏，虽然听起来很蠢。对。但你们确实在这么做。
Thank you, Jason. Yeah. So that you guys, you're making stuff. And then you guys, I'm going to kind of jump a little bit. You make what's known as the purple tapes, right? It was sort of like it was kind of like a demo, but not really, if I'm kind of right, it was like the first time you recorded. My question is, what was the first time that you guys said, all right, we're kind of making the,
谢谢你，杰森。对，所以你们在创作东西。然后你们，我要稍微跳跃一下。你们创作了所谓的“紫色磁带”，对吧？这有点像是一种小样，但又不太是，如果我没记错的话，这是你们第一次录音。我的问题是，你们第一次说“好吧，我们在做，让我们写首歌”，是什么时候？还是你们纯粹是个意外写出了一首歌？还是说你们特意去创作这些歌？这到底是怎么发生的？我很喜欢这种“我们志同道合，然后我有个想法”的概念。嗯，我们稍微分开了了一段时间，因为他回了纳米尔，然后我去了波多黎各圣胡安，我本打算去一年，但大概到了一半的时候，我甚至连一节课都没去过，我给他写了一信。
let's write a song, or did you kind of just by mistake write a song? Or did you go out to make these songs? Like, how did that happen? I love the idea of like, we're kind of aligned and I got an idea. Well, we got separated a little bit because he was back and, in Namers, and then I went to San Juan, Puerto Rico for, I was supposed to go for the year, but about halfway through, I hadn't even gone to a class, and I wrote him a letter.
就像，你还记得吗，我们以前经常写信？就像，我忘了我们以前写过信，但我写了，我想我给乔写了一封信，说，我们在波士顿碰头吧，我们终于要组建乐队了。他回信说，好的，一月见。你知道我的意思吗？顺便说一句，查尔斯，我找到那封信了。等等，乔，发生什么了？
Like, do you remember, like, we used to write letters? Like, I forgot that we used to write letters, but I wrote, I think I wrote Joe a letter saying, let's meet in Boston, and we'll start the band finally. And he wrote back and said, okay, we'll see you in January. You know what I mean? By the way, Charles, I found the letter. Wait, Joe, what happened?
我找到那封信了。不可能。真的吗？对。对。我老婆想去，或者我女朋友，她想翻翻我长大的那个房子的后备箱。我是说，里面什么都没有。
I found the letter. No way. Oh, really? Yeah. Yeah. My wife wanted to go, or my girlfriend, but she wanted to go over my trunk at my house that I grew up in. I mean, there's nothing in there.
然后我们走进去，心想，操，信在这儿。这太他妈酷了。太酷了。所以，乔，你收到了查尔斯这封信，然后你的反应是，你的反应是什么？它有点触动了你，你心想，好吧，酷，就像，你开始考虑这件事了。它在怂恿我退学。你们当时在学校学什么专业？就像，有什么你们不得不放弃的既定人生轨迹，为了去追求乐队？
And then we went in and it's like, fuck, the letter's in here. That's fucking rad. That's cool. So, Joe, you get this letter from Charles, and you're like, and you're like, what? It kind of gets, you're like, okay, cool, like, you start thinking about this. It was goading me to drop out. What were you guys studying in school? Like, was there, was there a path that you guys had to kind of derail to pursue the band?
我直到最后一刻都没有申报专业。对。有这么一个恶作剧，
I was undeclared until the last moment. Yeah. There was this, a spoof. on April 1st that people the undeclared were going to go to some war in Granada or something and I go I remember that I got to find a fucking major or you're going to have to serve in Grenada yeah so I just picked economics just to get out just to get out of the war but but it was all it was a spoof you know what about you Charles I was trying to remember what I was I, what happened when they did that spoof?
在4月1日那天，人们说未申报专业的学生要去格林纳达参加什么战争，然后我心想，我得找个他妈的专业，否则我就得去格林纳达服役了。对，所以我随便选了个经济学，只是为了脱身，为了逃避战争。但这一切都只是个恶作剧，你知道吗？你呢，查尔斯？我一直在努力回想我当时是什么情况，他们搞那个恶作剧的时候发生了什么？
That's the same thing. They caused us to think about the big, quite bigger questions. Because it was the college newspaper there, right? And UMass called the collegiate, whenever the fuck was called. But it was, and it was an April Fool's, and then it was like, yeah, it's going to be a draft.
那是一样的。它们让我们开始思考更大、更宏观的问题。因为那是那里的大学校报，对吧？马萨诸塞大学的校报叫什么来着，管他妈的叫什么呢。但那是愚人节玩笑，然后上面说，对，要开始征兵了。
Fuck. It's going to be a draft. You know, you believe, you believed it for like a good, I love that the paper knew how dumb and pliable the student body was. Yeah, man. But yeah, I was, like, thinking about Canada and stuff. Oh, we would have welcomed you. I mean, didn't care about, like, having to quit school.
操。要开始征兵了。你知道的，你相信了，你相信了整整好一段时间，我喜欢校报深知学生群体是多么愚蠢和轻信。是的，老兄。不过是的，我当时在考虑去加拿大之类的事情。噢，我们会欢迎你的。我是说，根本不在乎退学这回事。
I think we were both, like, looking for, like, reasons to drop out of school. Because school was, like, it was okay. But I don't know. It didn't kind of ring the bell quite. But clearly, you guys weren't novices at playing music, right? At this point, you guys were, you kind of knew what you were doing. No, no, no. A little bit.
我觉得我们俩都在寻找退学的理由。因为学校生活，感觉也就那样。但我也说不上来。它并没有真正引起共鸣。但显然，你们在玩音乐方面并不是新手，对吧？到了这个时候，你们已经，你们多少知道自己在做什么。不，不，不。一点点。
You knew some chords. How about that? Yeah, yeah. Like, I mean, in the best, I mean that in the best possible way. I don't mean that it was bad that we didn't know we were doing, but it wasn't like, we were like, shit, we've been like slaving away in the, you know, down in the basement, you know, for so many months now or so many years or no, it was none of that. It was just like a little rinky-dink, think, thing once in a while.
你们懂几个和弦。这样行吗？对，对。我是说，在最好的意义上，我这话是最好的意思。我并不是说我们不知道自己在做什么是一件坏事，但并不是说，我们心想，操，我们已经在地下室里苦心钻研了这么多个月或者好几年了，不，根本没有那回事。这只是一件偶尔搞搞的破烂小玩意儿。
Then let's drop out of school, start a band, see what that happens. It's amazing. And then I meet you in Boston and we met there. and he had an apartment on one side of the park. You were over there by Berkeley School of Music Joe. Remember you had that brown apartment? You had that epiphany where everything was brown in your life. You know, we'll come back to the brown epiphany.
然后，退学吧，组建个乐队，看看会发生什么。这太神奇了。然后我在波士顿遇到了你，我们在那儿碰头。他在公园的一边有一间公寓。乔，你当时就在伯克利音乐学院那边。还记得你那间棕色的公寓吗？你当时有了一种顿悟，发现你生活中的一切都是棕色的。你知道的，我们回头再聊那个棕色顿悟。
Charles, why am I so depressed? And you go in my fucking place is all brown. It's like, this could be the reason right here. Everything's brown. So you guys come back to it. And then first of all. And I feel guilty. Because Joey, like today, sometimes he'll dawn the brown.
查尔斯，为什么我这么沮丧？然后你走进我那他妈的房子，发现全都是棕色的。心想，这可能就是原因所在了。一切都是棕色的。所以你们又回到了这个话题。然后首先。而且我感到内疚。因为乔伊，就像今天，有时他会穿上棕色的衣服。
And he'll look nice. You know what I mean? And I'll say shit. You know, Joey looks nice and he's wearing brown. And I gave him shit about everything being brown. And I was frowning on the brown, but there was nothing wrong with it. It was like he had it together. Brown does get a very bad rap.
而且他看起来很好看。你知道我的意思吗？然后我会说，真该死。你知道的，乔伊看起来真不错，他穿着棕色衣服。我以前为每样东西都是棕色而责备过他。我曾经很不看好棕色，但其实它没什么毛病。就像他把一切都打理得很好。棕色确实名声不太好。
I don't think it's fair. Anyway, he lived in this brown apartment. And I lived in some other apartment, like, across the park. And we used to go to the, it was kind of naive, you know. we used to go to the club called the Ratskeller in Kenmore Square, which is no longer there. But it's an old venue because I believe my parents used to hang out there when they were teenagers. And anyway, we used to time how long the sets were for the bands because we had to figure out, well, how do we do that?
我觉得这不太公平。不管怎样，他住在那个棕色的公寓里。而我住在公园另一边的另一间公寓里。我们经常去，那种感觉挺天真的，你知道的。我们经常去肯莫尔广场上一家叫 Ratskeller 的俱乐部，现在已经没有了。但那是一个老场地，因为我相信我父母年轻时就经常在那里闲逛。总之，我们以前会掐算那些乐队的演出时间有多长，因为我们得弄清楚，嗯，我们怎么做到这一点？
You know, how do we get from just having a couple of rinky-ding tunes on our guitars? to having a full-fledged band but we're doing what those kids are doing. And so, yeah, we used to hang out in clubs in time. Oh, we need 25 minutes or whatever. And we need to, who do we got to talk to? You know, it takes a while to figure out, oh, you got to send a letter to that person.
你知道的，我们怎么从吉他上只有几首破烂小曲子，变成一个成熟的乐队，而且能做那些年轻人正在做的事。所以，没错，我们以前经常泡在俱乐部里掐算时间。哦，我们需要25分钟之类的。我们需要，我们得和谁谈谈？你知道的，这需要花时间去弄清楚，哦，你得给那个人写封信。
You got to send a betts to the sound man's girlfriend, Maria, she's the one you have to get the tape to. Here's the tape. There's this process of getting the tape to the right fucking person. and then finally get in the Monday night and then the Tuesday night and I suppose it's the same thing with comedy or anything, you know.
你得把磁带寄给调音师的女友玛丽亚，你得把磁带交个她。磁带在这里。把磁带送到正确的那个人手里的这个过程，然后终于安排在周一晚上演出，然后是周二晚上，我想这和喜剧或任何事情都一样，你知道的。
Was there a particular night that you had at the club that really caught on you? You could feel the audience was like, oh, these guys are rad. I'm going to sign up to come see them wherever they play next. Did you know that you had an audience? Like you started to have a fouling. Yeah, following was kind of developing.
你在俱乐部有没有哪天晚上的演出特别成功？你能感觉到观众心想，哦，这些家伙太棒了。不管他们去哪儿演我都得去捧场。你们知道自己已经拥有听众了吗？就像你们开始有了粉丝群一样。对，粉丝群在慢慢壮大。
Yeah. I'll tell you when we, when I knew we had something going. Yeah, yeah. Remember we were practicing at your apartment there in Fenway, and we heard a door knocking, the door knocked. Yeah. And go, shit, we're too loud.
对。我告诉你我们是什么时候发现自己有点名堂的。对，对。还记得我们在芬威区你的公寓里排练的时候，我们听到敲门声，门被敲响了。对。然后心想，操，我们声音太大了。
You know, they're going to, it was the maintenance guy. No. And we answered the door and goes, I just want to tell you guys, you guys are sounding good. Yeah. That's fucking rad. That's great. Yeah, yeah.
你知道的，他们要来，那是物业管理员。不是。我们去开门，他说，我只是想告诉你们，你们听起来真不错。对。这他妈太酷了。太棒了。对，对。
And this is a place right near Fenway? Yeah, yeah. You live in the Fenway at the time. In the Fenway, yeah. Yeah. And that's where we had our first real, well, our first real rehearsal space was somewhere else, but we eventually ended up with a, like a place with a sewer cap in it.
这是离芬威很近的一个地方吗？对，对。你当时住在芬威。在芬威，对。对。那就是我们拥有第一个真正的，嗯，我们第一个真正的排练空间在别的地方，但我们最终落脚在一个有下水道井盖的地方。
And it was down in the basement, and there was a bunch of bands down there. And it was very expensive even then. You know, it was like $500 a month for like a little windowless room with a sewer cap in it. And then when it rained, there were all these bugs suddenly like flying in the space
它在地下室里，下面有很多乐队。即使在当时，房租也很贵。你知道的，一个小小的没有窗户、里面有个下水道井盖的房间，一个月就要500美元。然后下雨的时候，突然间所有的虫子都飞进这个空间里，
and it smelled like shit and it's just a god awful place but that's like the best that we could get. Those are two opportunities where Jason would have quit the band with a shower and then the sewage space. And the rehearsal space. I'm happy to produce. I'll see you guys at the mixing studio.
而且闻起来像屎一样，简直是个糟糕透顶的地方，但那是我们能找到最好的了。那是两个让杰森直接带上花洒退乐队的时刻，先是洗澡那次，然后又是这个下污水的地方。还有排练空间。我很乐意担任制作人。我在混音室等你们。
But wait a second. Were you guys see you at the Hollywood Bowl? When did you guys become Pixies? What was the kind of the moment you guys became? How did that how did the name come up and what was the moment? Like, okay, now we're Pixies?
但等一下。你们是在好莱坞露天剧场见面吗？你们是什么时候成为“小精灵”乐队的？你们成为这个乐队的时刻是怎样的？这个名字是怎么来的，你们什么时候觉得“好吧，现在我们是小精灵乐队了”？
Well, I suppose it would have been our second show officially because the first show, we were listed as the Puxes. And so officially we were the Puxes in our first engagement. And then the second engagement, they got the spelling right. Typeo.
嗯，我想那应该是我们的第二场正式演出，因为第一场演出时，我们的名字叫 Puxes。所以我们在第一场演出时的官方名字是 Puxes。然后第二场演出时，他们把拼写给拼对了。拼写错误。
The Pixies. But I suppose Joey picked the name of the band. He was saddled that responsibility or took it upon himself. And you had a dictionary. You're right, Joe? I'm using a dictionary right now to hold up my computer. But I believe you were in the P's and there were a lot of P names.
The Pixies。但我想名字是乔伊选的。他承担了这个责任，或者说他主动揽下了这个活。你当时有一本词典，对吧，乔？我正用一本词典来垫着我的电脑呢。但我相信你当时翻到了P字母开头的页码，那里有很多P开头的名字。
You just threw a dart? It just looked good. You know, I had an X in the middle. That's funny. That's really funny. What's the definition? Mischivist Little Elf. I love that.
你只是随便扔了一支飞镖？看起来不错。你知道的，中间有个X。太有趣了。真的太有趣了。定义是什么？调皮的小精灵。我喜欢这个。
So that's a good one. That's going to start calling you, Willie. Thanks, man. Yeah, you have my little pig. See, get over here. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. So you guys are playing,
所以这是一个好名字。我要开始叫你威利了。谢谢，老兄。对，你拥有我的小猪。听着，过来吧。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。所以你们在演奏，
and you're practicing, and you were open... Sorry to go back to Purple Taps, but that was kind of your first recording. You guys were... Were you opening for other bands? Were you guys opening... Where did I read a long time? Were you opening for throwing muses or something?
你们在排练，你们当时在开场……抱歉回到紫色磁带的话题，但那可以说是你们的第一张录音作品。你们当时在……你们在为其他乐队暖场吗？你们当时在……我以前在哪儿看到过？你们是不是在为“抛弃缪斯”乐队暖场之类的？
Is that right? Do I have any of that right? Yeah, we did... Sure, yeah. We used to open up for them. Great band. Because they were a little further along than we were with all of the showbiz, you know, so they had a record out and they had a manager and stuff.
是这样吗？我记对了吗？对，我们做过……当然，是的。我们以前经常为他们暖场。伟大的乐队。因为他们在娱乐圈那一套上比我们稍微成熟一点，所以他们已经有一张唱片了，还有一个经理什么的。
But so we got hooked up with them and some of their people, you know, some of their crew and some of their manager. We had the same manager for a while, but the same producer for a little while. But I suppose that was, if there was any camaraderie, that would be the one band that was the, if we had any camaraderie. There wasn't a lot of camaraderie in Boston. For us, I think.
所以我们和他们以及他们的一些人搭上了线，你知道的，他们的一些工作人员和他们的经理。我们有一段时间共用同一个经理，还有一小段时间共用同一个制作人。但我想如果说有什么同事情谊的话，那就是这支乐队了，如果我们之间有什么同事情谊的话。波士顿当时并没有多少同事情谊。对我们来说，我觉得是这样。
I think I don't mean in a negative way even. I just mean that we didn't bother with that. It just seemed very clear and apparent to us that we had to get out of Dodge in order for it to mean anything significant. You know, we had to, because, you know, those bands that come through that are from other. places, you know, you see them come through. There was these Australian band, what are they called? Cellibate rifles.
我觉得我并不是在说消极的话。我的意思是，我们根本不屑于搞那些。在我们看来，非常清楚显的一点是，为了让这一切具有某种重大意义，我们必须离开道奇城（波士顿）。你知道的，我们必须这样做，因为，你知道的，那些从其他地方来的巡演乐队，你知道的，你看着他们一路巡演过来。当时有这么一支澳大利亚乐队，叫什么来着？禁欲步枪。
I remember the celibate rifles used to come through and they would have to draw 50 people or whatever every time they played at the Ratskiller. But it was like, wow, I don't know. They figured out how to get all the way here from Sydney or wherever they're from. And they're playing a show. And I don't know, it seems pretty fun to me.
我记得禁欲步枪乐队以前巡演时，每次在 Ratskeller 演出都得吸引50个人左右。但当时的想法是，哇，我不知道。他们竟然能从悉尼还是他们老家一路跑到这儿来。而且他们还在进行一场演出。而且我不知道，我觉得这对我来说挺有意思的。
So how do we get on that thing that they're doing? And of course, you know, it's not that glamorous, but it doesn't have to be glamorous when you're 20 years old. It's like, you want to travel or meet people or whatever, you know. I think that there's also that thing of like maybe you're from where you're from the place and you want to kind of be, there's something mysterious about a band that's coming from somewhere else. Like you want to be from somewhere else. I don't know if that's, if that figures into it either, like to just
所以我们怎么才能加入他们正在做的那种事情呢？当然，你知道的，这并没有那么光鲜亮丽，但当你20岁的时候，它也不一定非要光鲜亮丽。这就好比，你想去旅行、结识新朋友之类的，你知道的。我觉得还有那样一种感觉，就是也许你来自你出身的地方，而你想要，一个来自其他地方的乐队总有一种神秘感。就像你想来自其他地方一样。我不知道这是否，是否也是其中的一部分，就像
sort of like add to the mystique. Is that part of it or am I reading that wrong? Well, I suppose, Joey and I both probably were the same exact age and we both have the same. He's originally from the Philippines and I'm originally from Massachusetts but we both have the same kind of level of
为了给这种神秘感增添色彩。那是其中的一部分吗，还是我理解错了？嗯，我想，我和乔伊可能年龄完全一样，而且我们都有着相同的。他原本来自菲律宾，我原本来自马萨诸塞州，但我们都有着同等水平的
beetle knowledge and sort of beetle sort of brainwashing or whatever. You know what I mean? And other stuff from the 60s and 70s but putting just for the sake of conversation putting Beatles at the front of that pack.
披头士知识，某种程度上被披头士“洗脑”了之类。你知道我的意思吗？还有来自60和70年代的其他东西，但仅为了谈话方便，把披头士放在这一堆东西的最前面。
You know, so by the time we met up, when we were 17 or 18, it was like, oh, you like the Beatles, I like the Beatles, yeah. You know, it's kind of like we have that, that if you love the Beatles, then you have some affection for that lore, right? For the Liverpool thing and the little club. And when they went and played the strip clubs at Hamburg and blah, blah, blah, blah, the Star Club, and all of the history and all that.
所以当我们17、18岁相遇时，就觉得，噢，你喜欢披头士，我也喜欢披头士，对。你知道的，这就好像我们拥有了那种，如果你热爱披头士，你就会对那种传奇故事产生某种喜爱，对吧？对于利物浦的故事和小俱乐部。当他们去汉堡的脱衣舞俱乐部演出时，啦啦啦啦，还有星俱乐部，以及所有的历史和一切，
of that, you know, even if you've never been there, you have a lot of romantic feelings about those histories, you know? And so when you finally get to go on tour and then you're there and you're playing in those clubs in those same cities, you're kind of like going, ah, this is what it was like, and this is what it's like to record at the BBC Radio Studios or whatever, whatever the experience is. Sometimes it matches right up with your heroes. It'll be the same building, you know what I mean, the same stage or whatever.
所有这些，你知道的，即使你从未去过那里，你对这些历史也有很多浪漫的情怀，你知道的？所以当你终于可以去巡演，然后你身临其境，在那些相同城市的那些俱乐部里演出时，你心里差不多就会想，啊，原来这就是当年的感觉，这就是在 BBC 广播电台录音室录音的感觉，不管具体的经历是什么。有时它真的会和你的偶像不谋而合。会是同一栋建筑，你知道我的意思，同一个舞台什么的。
And so that's satisfying, you know, to be out on the map somewhere far from where you're from and be like, yep, but I'm doing the same thing that, you know, that the FAP 4 did. You know, it's as corny as that, you know, but that's the way it is. Was there a band that was really doing it when you guys got started that you kind of had your eye on and said, boy, if we could kind of go in that direction, we'd have something. That's where we want to go. Well, they were doing it in sort of tonally that you liked, that you were like, oh, this is kind of,
所以这让人感到满足，你知道的，在远离家乡的某个地图上的地方闯荡，心想，没错，我正在做的事，你知道的，跟披头士四人组做的一模一样。虽然听起来很老土，你知道的，但事实就是如此。当你们刚开始时，有没有哪支乐队是真正做出了名堂，让你们一直盯着并心想，天哪，如果我们能朝着那个方向发展，我们就能有所成就。那是我们想去的地方。嗯，他们在音乐调性上做出了你们喜欢的东西，让你们觉得，噢，这挺有，
was there any of that sort of influence-wise? At that time? I don't know, Joe. What did you think? I'm trying to think, did we talk about that kind of stuff? I like the Zulus. I remember the Zulus. I don't know that.
有没有哪种受其影响的乐队？在那个时候？我不知道，乔。你怎么看？我在想，我们当时讨论过这种事情吗？我喜欢祖鲁人乐队。我还记得祖鲁人乐队。我不知道那个。
They had something, you know, just wild guitar, wild vocalist. Yeah. I kind of want to jump to you, so you guys are doing this stuff, And you put this stuff together and you do, the purple tapes becomes basically, come on, Pilgrim, is that kind of, is that sort of right? Mm-hmm.
他们有某种特质，你知道的，狂野的吉他，狂野的主唱。是的。我有点想跳过这一段，所以你们在做这些东西，你们把这些东西拼凑起来，然后你们做出了“紫色磁带”，基本上就成了《快来吧，朝圣者》，是这样吗？嗯嗯。
But then your first real full-length record is Surfer Rosa. That's 1988. And that's kind of your introduction on a bigger scale to you guys to the world. And it's meant with a ton of critical acclaim. Like this puts you guys front and center and what's going on. I'll tell you something, man. knowing that you guys were coming on, I have a 15-year-old, I have three sons,
但你们真正意义上的第一张完整专辑是《Surfer Rosa》（粉红冲浪者）。那是1988年。那是你们向世界更大规模的介绍自己的作品。并且获得了大量的乐评赞誉。这把你们推到了聚光灯的正中心，展现了你们的实力。我跟你说个事，老兄。
my 15-year-old son is really into music, and we've been listening to you guys a lot the last couple days, like in the car and stuff, and I keep going, oh, man, we're going to have these guys on the podcast. And I was playing some of your songs, and I'm like, yeah, this record came out at 1988, my son's like, no fucking way. Because it seems so relevant musically,
知道你们要来上节目，我有一个15岁的儿子，我有三个儿子，我15岁的儿子非常喜欢音乐，过去几天我们一直在车里之类的地方听你们的歌。我一直说，哦，天呐，我们要请这几位老兄上播客了。我当时在放你们的一些歌，然后我就想，是的，这张唱片是1988年发行的，我儿子当时就说，他妈的怎么可能。因为从音乐角度来看，它听起来依然那么契合时代，
it seems so pressing, everything about it just, just, it seems so, for lack of a better word, modern or current or whatever, and you realize kind of how ahead of the curve you guys were in terms of just sonically, I think. Yeah. And I know that, and I'm sort of jumping all over the place, I know that since you guys, you put out five records in a really short period of time, and then you took a break for a number of years. And it was almost like after you guys, the first,
它听起来那么紧凑，它的方方面面，它听起来那么——借用一个不太恰当的词——摩登、潮流或者别的什么，你就会意识到，单纯从音色上讲，你们当年是多么走在时代的前面。是的。我知道，而且我有点东拉西扯，我知道自从你们在很短时间内发行了五张专辑，然后休息了很多年。几乎就像在你们第一次，
time you broke up, people went like, oh, we missed that. We didn't realize at the time how great these dudes were, what these guys were doing. Fuck you. Yeah. Was there a sense of fuck you? Okay, fuck, let's hear it. Was there ever fuck you? Like, or we told you so, man. We were making, and when other bands started coming, because I know everybody, I mentioned in the intro, like, Kurt Cobain, the guys in radio head, they've all talked about how much you guys influence them. And when you're kind of like, is there a little bit of like,
解散之后，人们才反应过来，噢，我们错过了。我们当时没有意识到这群家伙有多伟大，这群家伙在做些什么。去你的。是的。当时有没有那种“去你的”心态？好吧，去你的，说来听听。有没有过这种“去你的”？就像，或者“我们早就告诉过你们了，老兄”。我们在创作，当其他乐队开始出现的时候——因为我知道每个人，我在开场白里提到过，比如，库尔特·科本、电台司令的那些家伙，他们都谈到过你们对他们的影响有多大。当你们遇到这种情况时，有没有一种，
yeah, we're trying to tell you that, man? No. I don't know. I don't know if we take it all that seriously, you know, it's, I mean, we take it seriously in the sense that we thoroughly enjoy it, you know what I mean? Yeah, thoroughly enjoy the whole routine,
是的，我们之前就想告诉你们了，老兄的感觉？没有。我不知道。我不知道我们是不是把它看得那么严重，你知道的，我是说，我们在我们真正享受它的意义上把它看得很严重，你知道我的意思吗？是的，非常享受整个过程
the whole, whatever it is you got to do. You know what I mean? You know, play a show or, you know, I don't really like doing TV shows, but, you know, like, you got to do that sometimes. You know, go record a record and kind of, you know, you're in a friendly way competing with some other people maybe that are, I guess, contemporaries or whatever, you know.
无论做什么都要把整体做好。你知道我的意思吗？你知道的，去演一场演出，或者，你知道的，我其实不太喜欢上电视节目，但是，你知道的，有时候你不得不这么做。你知道的，去录制一张专辑，然后，你知道的，你可能是在以一种友好的方式与其他人竞争，我猜，那些是同代人或者别的什么，你知道的。
Plus competing with your heroes and everything, you know. So it's all really fun, but, you know, you can't take it too seriously. I don't know. I don't know, especially because I don't know if I, it's not like I feel like I went to, we went to music school for 20 years and slaved away for, you know, trying to just absorb all the stuff and worked so hard at it. I mean, we just love it and we like doing it and we're not, I don't know. So if other people like it, it's like, oh, good.
再加上与你的偶像竞争以及所有这些，你知道的。所以这一切都真的很有趣，但是，你知道的，你不能把它看得太严肃。我不知道。我不知道，尤其是因为我不知道我是不是，并不是说我觉得我去过，我们去上了20年音乐学校，然后苦苦奋斗了，你知道的，试图吸收所有这些东西并且为此付出了巨大的努力。我的意思是，我们只是热爱它，我们喜欢做这件事，而且我们不是，我不知道。所以如果其他人也喜欢它，那就觉得，哦，挺好的。
You know, I like you too. But Charles, you talk about, like doing TV shows and stuff and then I wanted to get in this and this is all in no particular order because I'm just kind of vomiting my obsession with you guys um i was thinking about how much you know the influence you guys have had well first of all i was thinking like in media like if you think about where is my mind where you guys felt about where is my mind being the the last song comes up a lot i'm sure so i'm sorry forgive me on the you know it plays over the very end of fight club when uh and then the kind of the world is falling apart and uh and that was i think for a lot of like a new generation like an introduction to you guys everybody was
你知道的，我也喜欢你。但是查尔斯，你谈到，比如上电视节目之类的东西，然后我想切入这个话题，而且这些内容没有特定的顺序，因为我只是在倾倒我对你们的痴迷，嗯，我在想你们有多，你知道的，你们所产生的影响，首先，我在想，比如在媒体里，如果你想想《Where is my Mind》，你们对《Where is my Mind》有什么感觉，作为经常出现的最后一首歌，我确信是这样的，所以抱歉，请原谅我，你知道的，它在《搏击俱乐部》的最后播放，当呃，然后世界开始崩塌，呃，这我认为对于很多新一代的人来说，就像是一个介绍你们给他们的契机，每个人都
like, holy shit. And when you see a song that you wrote, and I'd like to know where your mind was when you wrote that compared to what it's been applied to because now it's sort of represented in a different way, sort of the end of the world and stuff. What is that sort of that gap between where it was when it started and when you wrote it and what it ended up sort of symbolizing later
觉得，卧槽。而当你看到一首你写的歌，我想知道当你写下这首歌时，你的脑海里在想什么，与它后来被应用到的场景相比，因为它现在以一种不同的方式被呈现，有点像世界末日之类的。那种它最初创作时所在的状态，与它最终在后来象征的东西之间，那种差距是什么
because of its use in the movie? I don't really know, I don't have a lot of memory of putting it together or feeling that it was important so notable or anything like that. But my girlfriend
因为在电影中的使用？我真的不知道，我对于把它拼凑起来或者觉得它很重要、很出众之类的没有什么记忆。但是我的女朋友
was usually I played in the bathroom because it was the one private space in a little apartment, right? But she was in there doing makeup and said, and I saw I was at the bedroom with my guitar playing those chords and kind of working out maybe
通常我会在浴室里弹奏，因为那是一个小公寓里唯一的私密空间，对吧？但她在那里化妆，然后说，我看到我在卧室里拿着吉他弹奏那些和弦，大概是在琢磨
an arrangement of the song and the she stopped what she was doing and said finish that song she said that's a good one and I went oh okay and but that's the only memory I have of it really. I guess when I go back
这首歌的编曲，然后她停下手头的事说，把这首歌写完，她说这是一首好歌，然后我说，哦，好吧，但这就是我对它仅有的记忆了。我想当我回想
and I analyze it it just sounds like a silly little folk song or something you know that you know that I would have learned how to do stuff like that when I was at the, when I was in about third or fourth grade, I used to hang out with a lot of hippie kind of folk music types
并分析它时，它听起来就像是一首愚蠢的小民歌或者别的什么，你知道的，你会，你知道的，我是在大概三四年级的时候学会做类似的事情的，我经常和很多嬉皮士风格的民谣音乐人混在一起
in Newton, Massachusetts. And they schooled us in a lot of sing-alongy things that were kind of cool, actually, in retrospect, including Woody Guthrie and all that stuff, you know. But so to me, whereas my mind kind of just fits in with that, you know, here we go, third verse, same as the first verse. Here we go. You know, it's not even a sensical song or anything.
在马萨诸塞州牛顿市。他们教了我们很多那种大家一起合唱的东西，回想起来其实挺酷的，包括伍迪·格思里和所有那些东西，你知道的。但对我来说，《Where is my Mind》听起来就是那种，你知道的，我们走吧，第三段和第一段一样。我们走吧。你知道的，它甚至都不是一首有逻辑的歌或者别的什么。
It's just like some delightful words to trip over, you know, while you're kind of skipping through a melody and, you know, it's... I know, well, that's nice, but I, which is, that's interesting because we all have, I mean, I have had so many experiences listening to that song myself in sort of deep moments and that sort of haunting that Joey, that guitar. You know, that whole, like, it just... And it's had another...
它只是像一些讨人喜欢的词句，让你在穿过一段旋律时可以蹦出来，你知道的，它是……我知道，嗯，这很好，但我，也就是，这很有趣，因为我们所有人，我的意思是，我自己也曾有那么多次在一些深刻的时刻聆听这首歌的经历，还有乔伊的那种萦绕心头的吉他声。你知道的，那种整体的感觉，它就是……而且它还有着另一个……
life, as you probably know, like on social media and TikTok, like my kids see it all the time that it's used in all these different ways. And it's, again, Charles, I mean, I know it's so funny to hear you that like, yeah, you're just kind of coming up with it in a moment. And then it goes on to have this other application. It must be kind of trippy. Like, Joey, when you hear that guitar riffs, it must come up sometimes you hear it. And do you remember recording it when you guys recorded it? Do you remember that day or thinking like, this is cool? I do remember. I remember it. I remember you showed us a song at your apartment. We had some Vietnamese food. And then that was the, that part came right away and it was like, I'm done. That's what I said, basically, I'm done.
生命，正如你可能知道的那样，比如在社交媒体和TikTok上，我的孩子们经常看到它被用在所有这些不同的方式中。而且，再次强调，查尔斯，我的意思是，我知道听到你说“是的，你只是在某一刻想出来的，然后它就去有了这种别的应用”是多么有趣。这一定很奇妙。就像乔伊，当你听到那个吉他riff时，你有时一定会听到它。你还记得你们录音时的情景吗？你还记得那一天吗，或者当时觉得：这很酷？我确实记得。我记得。我记得你在你的公寓里给我们展示了一首歌。我们吃了一些越南菜。然后那个部分马上就出来了，当时就像是，我完成了。我基本上就是这么说的，我完成了。
Because I wanted to do that little Chuck Berry thing, but I didn't do the double note that did it, did it, did it. So I just want to fit that in and they go, ah. Yeah, it's good. Does it matter more or less for a song to have a long life of, like, would you rather a song be super duper memorable because of its tune, because of its melody, or because of the words that it says? Like, you know, Charles, you were saying, it's like, you know, it's just like a couple of chorus here and some words that you might, you know, like, what is more important to you of the staying power?
因为我想做那个小小的查克·贝里式的弹奏，但我没有做那个双音，而是哒，哒，哒。所以我只是想把它融入进去，然后他们说，啊。是的，这很好。一首歌拥有漫长的生命力，这到底是更重要还是不那么重要？比如，你更希望一首歌因为它的曲调、它的旋律而超级无敌难忘，还是因为它的歌词？比如，你知道的，查尔斯，你刚才说，这就像是，你知道的，这只是一对副歌和一些你可能会，你知道的，词句，什么对你来说是保持一首歌长盛不衰的更重要的因素？
of a song, the melody or the words that what you're trying to say, you know, does it matter? I mean, both work, right? I mean, you know, because you have people that feel very warm or poignant or whatever about a particular lyric or whatever or the meaning of the song. But then a lot of times it's just sounds and combinations of sounds and chords and, you know, things that give you the chills or the goosebumps and, you know, and, you know, I don't know. I mean, I don't think any of our, I mean, half of our audiences, like, doesn't speak English. So they speak rock English, you know what I mean?
旋律还是歌词，也就是你试图表达的东西，你知道的，这重要吗？我的意思是，两者都管用，对吧？我的意思是，你知道的，因为有的人会对某句特定的歌词或歌曲的含义感到非常温暖、辛酸或别的什么。但很多时候，它只是声音、声音的组合、和弦，以及，你知道的，那些让你起鸡皮疙瘩的东西，然后，你知道的，然后，你知道的，我不知道。我的意思是，我不认为我们的任何，我的意思是，我们一半的观众，就像是，不会说英语。所以他们说的是摇滚英语，你知道我的意思吗？
So I suppose they can connect to it a little bit. Yeah, that's a good point. You know, there's a lot of other stuff mixed in with it, I suppose, when you, so I don't want to put too much. It's nice when words can be good, but, and when it's a, when someone can declare, oh, this is indeed a fine libretto, you know. But at the end of the day, it's a rock music context. So it's like a, there's a lot of, ba-p-p-pah-pah-pah-pah-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ma-ma-ha. You know what I mean?
所以我猜他们还是能稍微和它产生一点共鸣。是的，说得好。你知道的，里面还混杂了很多其他东西，我想，当你，所以我不愿赋予它太多意义。歌词写得好固然很好，而且当它是一首，当有人能宣称，哦，这确实是一部不错的歌剧剧本，你知道的。但归根结底，它是一个摇滚乐的语境。所以这就像是，有很多的，吧-p-p-pah-pah-pah-pah-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ma-ma-ha。你知道我的意思吗？
There's a lot of other kind of elements that are kind of coming to the party also. You know what I mean? Where's the most surprising place you have found a dedicated fan base? What corner of the world are surprised you? Like, wow. Like, do you, like, show up and listen? has been in all of a sudden you're like, wow, we got a lot of fans. Like we found that in Iran, we have a big audience.
还有很多其他种类的元素也加入了这场派对。你知道我的意思吗？你发现过最令人惊讶的忠实粉丝群是在哪里？世界的哪个角落让你感到惊讶？就像，哇。比如，你，就像是，去演出然后听着？然后突然之间你觉得，哇，我们有好多粉丝。比如我们在伊朗发现，我们有大批的观众。
No joke. Yeah, for a podcast. No way. Yeah, yeah. We were like, what? We were like, what? We're lucky enough to have a pretty far-flung audience, but I don't know that, like, I don't know if we've discovered that enclave of, like, you know, whatever,
不开玩笑。是的，为了一个播客。不可能。真的，真的。我们当时想，什么？我们当时想，什么？我们很幸运能拥有一个相当广泛的粉丝群，但我不知道，就像是，我不知道我们是否发现了那个聚居地，比如，你知道的，某个地方，某个远离常规路径的地方，比如，我不知道，比如印度腹地或者类似的地方，你知道的，他们不知怎么就发现了我们的音乐或者别的什么。但我们的确在很多地方演出。所以我正努力想一想我们演过的一些地方。我的意思是，说到像葡萄牙，我们在葡萄牙真的很受欢迎。所以，是的。你们觉得怎么样，查尔斯和乔伊，
someplace and somewhere way off of the beaten path, like, I don't know, like inner India or somewhere like that, you know, where they've somehow discovered our music or whatever. But we do play a lot of places. So I'm trying to think of some place we've played. I mean, talking about like Portugal, like we do really well down on Portugal. So, yeah. What did you guys think about, Charles and Joey,
你们怎么看人们过去谈论的方式，他们过去试图，因为我很讨厌人们被归类，但当他们试图称其为什么柔和、安静、吵闹或者别的什么时，他们用的术语是什么？你还记得他们过去用来形容你们的词吗？吵闹，安静，吵闹。是的，吵闹，安静，吵闹。是的。
what did you guys think about what was the way that people used to talk about, they used to try to like, because I hate when people get categorized, but when they tried to call it like the soft, quiet, loud or whatever, what was the term that they used? Do you remember that they used to try to describe you guys? Loud, quiet, loud. Yeah, loud, quiet, loud. Yeah.
而当你听到这个时，你是什么感觉，哦，好吧，那只是我们，随便啦。我们当然没有发明它，你知道的。我的意思是，柴可夫斯基的《1812序曲》里可是有他妈的大炮呢，你知道的。那是真的。这非常真实，是的。是的。我正要说点关于巡演的事。所以你们还在巡演，听起来好像有很多巡演。
And when you heard that where you were like, oh, okay, well, that's just us, like, whatever. We certainly didn't invent it, you know. I mean, Chakowsky's 1812 Wolverichere had fucking cannons, you know. That's true. That's very true, yeah. Yeah. I was just going to say something about touring. So you guys still tour, it sounds like a lot.
当你们巡演时，你们会在演出前见面吗？还是你们第一次见面是在舞台上？比如，你们在演出前会在后台闲逛吗？是的。我们在演出前大约一个小时闲逛。我们集合，我们的巡演经理办公室里有一台浓缩咖啡机。我们都去那里喝一杯浓缩咖啡。然后我们坐在化妆室里。
And when you do, do you see each other before a show, or is the first time you see each other when you're on stage? Like, do you hang out backstage before the show? Yeah. We hang out about an hour before the show. We convene, and there's an espresso machine in our tour manager's office. we all go there and get an espresso. And then we sit down on the dressing room.
然后我们那里有一些木吉他。有一把木吉他。然后我想戴夫，你应该找点东西来敲打。然后我们唱大约半小时、45分钟，然后有点像，哦，是的，我们就是这样演奏的。然后，然后我们就去巡演了。但是，是的，我们真的不，我们不再住在同一个城市了。所以我想我们有，我不知道这算不算，我不想说我们懒惰，但我们做这件事已经太久了
And then we have like some acoustic guitars there. There's one acoustic guitar. And then I think Dave, you should just find something to tap on. And then we sing for about a half an hour, 45 minutes, and kind of go, oh, yeah, that's how we play. And then, and then we go on tour. But yeah, we don't really, we don't live in the same city anymore. So I think we have, I don't know if it's, I don't want to call it that we're lazy, but we've just been doing it for so long
以至于我们真的，是的。没关系，我们很懒。厌倦了，一遍又一遍又一遍。你们，你们，所以你们，所以我之前提到过，我想跳回去，所以你们在短时间内出了五张专辑，以《Trompe le Monde》结束，这又是，
that we don't really Yeah. It's okay, we're lazy. Over it, over and over and over. Do you guys, do you guys, so you guys, so I mentioned before, I kind of want to jump back, so you do five records in a short amount of time, ending with Tramplamon, which, again,
又一张这样的专辑，多年后每个人都觉得，哦天哪，这张专辑太棒了，我们当时就该认出它的好。然后你们休息了很长时间。你们基本上解散了，我不知道，10年左右？12年。在那段时间里，你们各自去做了不同的事情。
another one of those records that years later everybody's like, oh man, this record is amazing and we should have recognized it at the time. And you take a long break. You guys were basically broken up for I don't know, 10 years or something? 12 years. And in that time, you all go off and do different things.
弗兰克，你做了，我叫你弗兰克，因为在那段时间里，你被称为，你被称为弗兰克·布莱克。你以弗兰克·布莱克的名义发行了一堆专辑。当然，《Teenager of the Year》，我不知道这个。《Teenager of the Year》，顺便说一句，我只想说这算是一个小小的Pixies花絮，如果可以的话，查尔斯。我不知道你其实在高中时被评为过年度青少年。我在某处读到过，那是，这是真的吗，你被评为过年度青少年？那是什么意思？那是自我毕业的高中颁发的一个奖项。
Frank, you do, I call you Frank, because in that time, you were known as, you were known as Frank Black. You put a bunch of records out as Frank Black. Of course, Teenager of the Year, I didn't know this. Teenager of the Year, by the way, I just want to say sort of Pixie's side note, if I can, Charles. I didn't know that you had actually been named teenager of the year in high school. I read that somewhere that that's, is that true that you're named teenager of the year? What's that mean? It's an award that was given at the high school that I graduated from.
我不知道为什么要颁发这个奖，但我认为这就像是一个，这就像是给那个没惹太多麻烦的好孩子的一个奖，但他远离了麻烦，而且看起来人挺不错。所以我们得给他点什么。这就像是一个小小的，嘿，你是年度青少年。我是班上的幽灵。等一下，那是真的吗？那是真的吗？
I don't know why it's given, but I think it's like a, it's like for the good kid that didn't do that much, but like he stayed out of trouble and he seemed nice. And so we got to give him something. And it's like a little, hey, you're the teenager of the year. I was the class ghost. Wait, is that true? Is that true?
班上的幽灵？有一年年鉴上没有我的照片。我拒绝让他们拍我的照片或者做任何事。所以我甚至，我甚至都不存在。乔，多么完美的搭配。你俩一个是班上的幽灵，一个是年度青少年，凑在了一起。就像是命中注定的一样，兄弟。就像是写在星象里的一样。
The class ghost? No pictures of me one year on the yearbook. I refuse to have my picture taken and anything. So I wasn't even, I didn't even exist. Joe, what a perfect pairing. You're the class ghost and the teenager of the year together. Like, it's almost like meant to be, man. It's like written in the fucking stars.
然后你们和Pixies度过了这12年的间歇期。然后你们重新- 是那样的吗？那只是为了做别的事情而暂停吗？还是有积怨？然后你们觉得，不，去他妈的，我们不干了？哦，不，我们解散了。乐队解散了，我想我们不得不去付出我们的代价。
And so then you guys have this 12-year hiatus from Pixies. And you get back to- Is that what it was? Was it just a hiatus to do other stuff? Or was there acrimony? And you guys were like, no, fuck this, let's not do it. Oh, no, we broke up. The band was broken up and we had to go pay our dues, I suppose.
因为我们第一次的时候并没有真正付出代价。我的意思是，我并不是说一切都超级容易。但是，你知道的，不管怎样。这就像人们常说的，每个乐队都有五年期限。你在这五年里把一切都做了，然后一切都土崩瓦解了。然后是我们把它弄崩的。所以我们只是，不管怎样，在水里踩水踩了20年。我的意思是，不是踩水，因为我知道金实际上在她的
Because we didn't really pay our dues the first time around. I mean, I'm not saying that it was all super easy. But, you know, whatever. It was like every band's got five years, as they say. And you do it all in five years and it all kind of implodes. And then we implode it. And so we were just, whatever, tread and water for 20 years. And I mean, not tread in water because I know Kim actually had some pretty big success with her.
她的乐队The Breeders那里取得了一些相当大的成功。她有过一首大热单曲之类的。所以，而且，你知道的，我不是，你知道的，我不应该，这听起来像是在抱怨，但我没有。但是，你知道的，并不是说我，或者我们当时在做所有这些惊人的
With her band, The Breeders. And she had a big hit and everything. So, and, you know, I mean, I wasn't, you know, I shouldn't, it sounds like a complaining, but I'm not. But, you know, it's not like I was, or we were doing all these amazing. projects that were, you know, so successful, whatever. You just kind of hovering around and kind of staying in it as best as you can for a whole, and, you know, plenty of humbling experiences, I suppose, to go along with it. Well, you inspired in that time, little do you know.
项目，你知道的，是如此成功之类的。你只是到处闲晃，尽你所能地维持下去，而且，你知道的，伴随着很多 humbling（谦卑的/令人羞耻的）经历，我想，这一切随之而来。嗯，你当时给予了启发，你可能不知道。
I will tell you one more sidebar, Charles, which is years ago, what is it, 2025. So like 14 years ago, I was trying to come up with, I had this idea for this show that became a very little watch show on Netflix called Flake that I wrote. And I was flying over to the UK. And I was just outlining this, like, dumb idea. And I was like, what is this thing? What is this thing? And I was going to meet my partner Chappie,
我再告诉你一个小花絮，查尔斯，那就是多年前，什么时候，2025年。所以大约14年前，我当时正试图想出，我有一个关于这个节目的想法，后来在Netflix上变成了一个观看量很小的节目，叫做《Flake》，是我写的。我当时正飞往英国。我只是在草拟这个，像是，愚蠢的想法。然后我在想，这是什么东西？这是什么东西？我当时要去见我的合伙人查皮（Chappie），
who's a great friend of Jason's. He got the greatest name in the world. And Mark Chappell, a great writer who wrote, we've written a bunch of stuff together. He wrote, Is This Thing On With me, with Bradley, our new movie. So anyway, so I'm going over there, and I was listening to Teenager of the Year. and I was listening to Freedom Rock, that track Freedom Rock,
他是杰森的好朋友。他拥有世界上最棒的名字。马克·查佩尔（Mark Chappell），一个伟大的编剧，他写过，我们一起写过很多东西。他和我一起写了《Is This Thing On》，还有布拉德利，我们的新电影。所以无论如何，我正飞过去，当时我正在听《Teenager of the Year》。我当时正在听《Freedom Rock》，那一首《Freedom Rock》，
and it goes, for you guys who don't know, it goes, my name is Chip and I'm different. And I just wrote that down, that lyric down in the thing while I was writing the synops. It was no idea. And later, a couple days later, Mark and I were writing, and I looked back in my notes and I said, this guy's name, and it really helped me kind of get into this guy,
歌词是这样的，对于你们不知道的人来说，它是这样的，我的名字叫奇普，我很与众不同。我当时就把那个歌词写下来了，写在大纲里。完全没有概念。后来，几天后，马克和我正在写作，我回看我的笔记，我说，这个家伙的名字，它真的帮我进入了这个家伙的角色，
into this character that ended up becoming this character chip in my show, and it was based on listening to Freedom Rock. So just so you know, when you thought you were doing nothing, you ended up years later really inspiring me. So thank you. That's cool. Oh, I'm glad that worked out. You know, I think it's just, you know,
进入了这个最终成为我的剧里的奇普这个角色的状态，而它是基于听了《Freedom Rock》灵感而来的。所以你们要知道，当你们以为自己什么都没做的时候，多年后你们真的大大启发了我。所以谢谢你们。这很酷。哦，很高兴它能起作用。你知道的，我认为这只是，你知道的，
if you have any kind of love of language, and it doesn't even have to be, I don't know, academic or whatever. It's just the way that, you know, the way you play around with words, words that you like, you know, sometimes you find a word or a name or something, then somehow you incorporate it into your thing. Yeah. We'll be right back. And back to the show.
如果你对语言有任何热爱，甚至不必是，我不知道，学术的或者别的什么。这只是那种，你知道的，你玩弄单词的方式，你喜欢的单词，你知道的，有时你发现一个单词或名字或其他什么，然后不知怎么的你把它融入到了你的创作中。是的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。
Anyway, so you guys go do that. And then what happens, what is the moment, 12 years after you break up, who calls whom, who goes? Because you guys all get back, right? Joe and you, Charles, and Kim. You guys, what's the moment? Who makes the first call? Who has the idea like, fuck, let's get the band. Yeah, was it just a text that said, you up?
无论如何，所以你们去做了那个。然后发生了什么，是什么时刻，在你们解散12年后，谁给谁打了电话，谁去的？因为你们最后都复合了，对吧？你和乔，还有金。你们，那是怎样的时刻？谁打了第一通电话？谁有了这个想法，操，让我们把乐队重新组建起来。是的，难道只是一条写着“你睡了吗”的短信吗？
No, because it was still kind of, believe it or not, I suppose people sent texts, but I think that even in 2003 or whenever this was, you know, people weren't quite glued to their phones. It was a fax. Of course, the way they are. But I did an interview on a radio show in London, and it was an early morning show, you know, a lot of joking around and kind of, and, you know, they're like a bunch of Brits, and they're talking circles around me, you know, and they're kind of being all nuanced and everything. I'm only getting half of what's going on.
不，因为当时仍然有点，信不信由你，我想人们确实发短信，但我认为即使在2003年或者无论什么时候，你知道的，人们并没有完全粘在手机上。那是一份传真。当然，他们就是那样。但我当时在伦敦的一个电台节目中做采访，那是一个清晨的节目，你知道的，有很多开玩笑的内容，而且，你知道的，他们是一群英国人，他们围着我绕着圈子说话，你知道的，他们表现得很有细微差别之类。我只听懂了一半在发生什么。
But anyway, I start kind of trying to joke around with them. They're saying, do you see the other band members? I'm like, yeah, we jam all the time. And I'm just kind of being sarcastic, you know, and kidding around a little bit. And then they knew I was being sarcastic, but they decide to pretend sort of that I wasn't. Because I, oh, we got you. You said it. You said you guys are back together and you're jamming. But I was being obviously, like I said, not serious.
但无论如何，我开始试着跟他们开玩笑。他们说，你还见其他乐队成员吗？我说，见啊，我们经常一起即兴演奏。我当时只是在开玩笑，你知道的，稍微逗着玩一下。然后他们知道我在开玩笑，但他们决定假装我不是在开玩笑。因为我，哦，我们抓到你了。你说了。你说你们复合了，你们在即兴演奏。但我当时显然是在，就像我说的，不是认真的。
But they, after I left the radio station, they kept, that was their little thing they talked about, I guess, the rest of their show or whatever. Because by the time that I got home to my hotel or whatever, like I don't remember barely, but there was a world, remember there was a, where we'd suddenly CNN was 24 hours. And so everyone was kind of aware of like the ticker. Yes. You know, that kind of the idea of a ticker, of a news ticker, you know.
但他们，在我离开电台之后，他们一直在谈论这个，我想这就是他们接下来的节目里或者其他什么一直在聊的话题。因为当我回到酒店时，我不记得具体怎么回事了，但当时出现了一个世界，还记得当时有一个，我们突然CNN有了24小时新闻。所以每个人都知道了滚动字幕这回事。是的。你知道的，那种滚动字幕的概念，新闻滚动字幕，你知道的。
And for most, I suppose, Joe Blow people, common people that weren't like following stocks or whatever. It would have been the CNN would have been the ticker that they would have been aware of. And somehow our reunion made it onto the ticker. Made it onto the ticker. And so, like, people started, so I don't know if Joey might have called me, I think, and said, like, what the fuck is going on? Because I'm watching CNN here, and we're like back together.
对于大多数，我猜，普通人、凡夫俗子来说，他们不怎么关注股票或者别的什么。CNN的滚动字幕会是他们所知道的。不知怎么的，我们的复合上了滚动字幕。上了滚动字幕。所以，就像，人们开始，所以我不知道乔是不是给我打过电话，我想是的，然后说，这他妈是怎么回事？因为我在这里看CNN，而我们居然复合了。
Joe, so you're reading the ticker and you're like, Joe, you're like, what the fuck, man, are we getting back together? Like, what's going on? I was pissed I didn't buy Apple. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. No, no. Get in line, man.
乔，所以你当时在看滚动字幕，然后你就像是，乔，你就像是，他妈的怎么回事，兄弟，我们要复合了吗？这到底是怎么回事？我当时很生气自己没有买苹果股票。对。对，对。排队去吧，兄弟。
Yeah, I suppose, yeah. I kind of remember a little differently, but yeah. Yeah, yeah. I love this. I do remember Charles calling me. I guess I didn't have CNN, you know. At the time. I try not to watch, I still try not to watch the news.
是的，我想，是的。我记忆中的情况稍微有点不同，但是的。是的，是的。我喜欢这个。我确实记得查尔斯给我打电话。我猜我当时没有CNN，你知道的。那时候。我尽量不看新闻，我到现在还是尽量不看新闻。
That's smart. it's always been bad, but especially now, I just can't fucking watch it. But anyway, yeah, he called and then that was it. Wait, wait, that's it. I think I think Joey would agree to call Kim. I said, would you call Kim and see if she's up for it? Well, my friend starts saying, you guys are getting back together. And it's like, what?
这很明智。新闻一直都很烂，但尤其是现在，我他妈的实在看不下去。但无论如何，是的，他打了电话，然后就是这样。等等，等等，就这样？我想我想乔会同意给金打电话。我说，你能不能给金打个电话，看她愿不愿意？好吧，我的朋友开始说，你们要复合了。然后就像是，什么？
And I didn't know, you know, until. I got the call from Charles and then it's like, oh, it is true. You know? Because every five years, people would tell me what are you guys going to get back together? There's always this rumor
我不知道，你知道的，直到我接到查尔斯的电话，然后就像是，哦，这是真的。你知道吗？因为每隔五年，人们就会告诉我你们什么时候复合？总是会有这样的谣言
that we're going to be going to Coachella or something. There's always this thing. But Joe, you must have known, like you guys had to have known because you guys were so beloved and so missed that, like, what happened? Like the touring company or manager,
说我们要去科切拉音乐节或者别的什么。总是会有这种事。但乔，你当时一定知道，就像你们一定知道，因为你们是如此受人喜爱和怀念，以至于，到底发生了什么？比如巡演公司或经理，
whoever calls and goes like, hey, guys, this is great. Like, we're stoked. Yeah, but I'm sure that there's still that other element, which is much more sort of delicate and nuanced, which is, I don't want to be the one to say, hey, guys, should we do this? Because the other person on the other end of the line might be like,
无论是谁打来电话说，嘿，伙计们，这太棒了。就像，我们很激动。是的，但我确信仍然有另一个因素，要微妙和细腻得多，那就是，我不想成为那个说“嘿，伙计们，我们该这么做吗？”的人，因为电话那头的另一个人可能会说，
yeah, no, fuck that. What are you talking about? I'm not getting back together with you. Like, someone's got to pull their pants down first. I would imagine that's a real delicate part of any sort of reunion with any band, with any group. Pulling the pants down is certainly a delicate. You know, is there a belt?
对，不，去他妈的。你在说什么？我才不跟你复合呢。总得有人先把裤子脱了。我想对于任何乐队、任何团体的任何形式的复合来说，这都是一个真正微妙的部分。把裤子脱了当然是一个微妙的。你知道的，有皮带吗？
Is it zippers? Is it a button fly? You know, like, it's complicated. Well, Charles, you were busy. So, you know, Kim, Dave and I got together and to practice the songs. Wow. Together, because you were somewhere else.
是拉链吗？还是纽扣的？你知道的，这很复杂。好吧，查尔斯，你当时很忙。所以，你知道的，金、戴夫和我聚在一起练习歌曲。哇。在一起，因为你在别的地方。
And then we made a deal, no pun intended, that if this thing's going to sound like, crap with the three of us. We're going to shake hands and move on. Oh, wow. I didn't know about this deal. Yeah, yeah. Whoa.
然后我们达成了一个协议，双关语，如果这件事听起来对我们三个来说像一堆狗屎。我们就握手言和，各奔东西。哦，哇。我不知道这个协议。是的，是的。哇。
Well, it's true, though. If it wasn't going to work out. It seems reasonable enough. Very reasonable. But the first three songs that we went over, we just smiled and go, oh, my God, we still, it still fucking sounds the same. Because my marshal's, my marshal has sharpy marks on it.
不过，这倒是真的。如果行不通的话。这听起来挺合理的。非常合理。但我们排练的前三首歌，我们只是笑着说，哦，天哪，我们听起来，听起来他妈的还是老样子。因为我的马歇尔（Marshall）音箱上
So all I had to do is like dial it in. And that was that sound. But more importantly, the quantizing of the groove. I mean, we had it, you know. That had to be such a rush to hear that the first time. Yeah, no shit. It was almost comical. Yeah, yeah.
有记号笔的标记。所以我只需要把它拨到那个位置。那就是那个声音。但更重要的是，律动的量化。我的意思是，我们做到了，你知道的。第一次听到那个声音一定像是一场狂喜。废话。几乎有点滑稽。是的，是的。
Wow. Yeah. What did you say the quantizing of the groove? What does that mean? You know, the way the bass and the rhythm, it pushes and pulls. You mean the actual combination of your sounds individually together to create one singular noise? Just like the nuances of the push and pulls. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
哇。是的。你刚才说什么律动的量化？那是什么意思？你知道的，贝斯和节奏融合的方式，它有推有拉。你是说你们各自的声音单独结合在一起创造出一种单一噪音的实际组合？就像是推拉的细微差别。是的，是的，是的，是的。
We had it, you know. Oh, that's great. It's, you know, it's just a... And you had settings on your amplifier that were specific to that pixie sound that you had to get back to? Yeah, yeah, it was sharpied on there, so I was just like... That's wild. That's cool. It's like a recipe.
我们做到了，你知道的。哦，太棒了。这，你知道的，只是一个……而且你的功放上有专门针对那种Pixies之声的设置，你必须把它调回那个状态？是的，是的，上面用记号笔标着呢，所以我当时就直接……太疯狂了。这很酷。这就像是一份食谱。
That's really cool. Yeah. That's awesome. So by the way, so Charles, you go and you get with these guys, you don't realize that they've, until today, that they made this deal, that they're like, hey, if it doesn't work out, we're not going to do it. No, but, you know, I didn't, you know,
真的很酷。是的。太棒了。所以顺便问一下，查尔斯，你去了，和这几个人在一起，直到今天你才知道他们曾达成过这个协议，他们当时想，嘿，如果行不通，我们就不干了。不，但是，你知道的，我没有，你知道的，
I suppose I had other concerns or whatever. Okay, so let me just ask you this. Because I want, we got a lot to get in. And I got to let you guys go in a minute. what you know I outlined again and not at risk of embarrassing you which I talk about influence on other musicians and artists throughout the years did you ever is there a moment for each of you that kind of sticks out like a cool moment that somebody came and said somebody that you like or somebody whose music you really
我想我有别的顾虑或者别的什么。好吧，那让我问你这个。因为我想，我们有很多内容要谈。而且我一会儿得让你们走了。你知道我刚才提到过的，而且冒着让你尴尬的风险——虽然我谈到了你们多年来对其他音乐人和艺术家的影响——你们每个人心中有没有这样一个时刻，某个让你印象深刻的酷炫时刻：一个你喜欢的人，或者一个你非常欣赏其音乐的人，走过来说，嘿，伙计，我真的很喜欢你们做的事？有没有过这样的时刻？因为我在我的职业生涯中有过这样的时刻。我想我们都有，当一个我们尊重的人走过来对你说，嘿，你，干得不错。最大，最他妈大的那一个，查尔斯。
respond to who said hey man I really like what you guys do is there a moment like that because I've had moments like that in my in my career I think we all have where somebody who we respect comes and says like, hey, you, you done good. The biggest, the biggest damn one, Charles.
来吧。那是谁？我们当时在奥菲姆剧场（O'Frium）演出，然后我们的巡演经理说，嘿，有人想在我们的演出结束后过来打个招呼。他说，哦，这他妈是谁啊？他说，哦，是大卫·鲍伊（David Bowie）。
Come on. Who's that? We were playing at the O'Frium at the time, and then our tour manager says, hey, someone wants to come by after our show and say hello. He goes, oh, like, who the fuck is this? He goes, oh, it's David Bowie.
就像是，哦，哇。是的，大卫·鲍伊过来了，就在这个俱乐部里，说，他们喜欢我们。这真的很酷。那会给你的未来几年提供不少动力。就是这样。对吧？是的。
It's like, Oh, wow. Yeah, David Bowman came by and this is the club and said, they like us. That's really cool. That would give you some fuel for a few years. That was it. Right? Yeah.
给你。查尔斯不记得了。不，不，不，不。毫无疑问，他的分量是最重的，我想。在那种意义上，你知道的，在音乐界王室之类的意义上。是的，绝对的。是的，查尔斯，对你来说还有其他的吗？
There you go. Charles doesn't remember. No, no, no, no. Definitely he looms the largest, I suppose. In those kinds of terms, you know, in terms of like a, you know, musical royalty or whatever. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. Charles, were there other ones for you,
比如其他一些你喜欢的乐队，他们更，我的意思是，鲍伊是一个标志性人物。没有比这更大的了。嗯，我记得我们做的第一个电视节目是在纽约，你还记得有一个由大卫·桑born（David Sanborn）主持的深夜节目吗？哦，是的。是的。我忘了它叫什么名字了，
like other sort of like bands who you liked who were like more, I mean, Bowie is like an iconic. It doesn't get bigger. Well, I remember the first TV show we did was in New York with, do you remember there was a late night program hosted by David Sandborn? Oh, yeah. Yeah. And I forget what the name of it was,
但他在节目上会请四五位不同的嘉宾。他们都会上台表演一首歌。他们在最后会有一段即兴演奏。如我所记，那有点尴尬。但他请来了太阳乐团（Sun Ra Arkestra），你知道的。所以他们是那种，你知道的，老爵士乐手，你知道我的意思吗，他们已经在这一行混了很久，见多识广。他们是……
but he would have on like four or five different people. And they'd all come on and do a song. They did this jam at the end. which was a little awkward, as I recall. But he had on the Sunrah Orchestra, Orchestra, you know. And so they were these, like, you know, old jazz musicians, you know what I mean, who had really kind of been around for a long time and kind of seen it all. And they were...
无论如何，我们演奏了一首荒谬的歌曲叫《Tame》，那是“吵闹-安静-吵闹”动态的缩影。然后我们有那种安静的部分和吵闹的部分，对吧？它确实变得非常吵闹，而且，你知道的，我猜我的嗓门很大或者别的什么，而且在编曲和我们的音乐理念方面它非常极简。
So anyway, we did this ridiculous number called Tame, which is the epitome of the loud, quiet, loud dynamic. and then we had the and the quiet part and the loud part, right? It does get quite loud and, you know, I guess I have a loud voice or whatever and it's very minimalist in terms of its orchestration and our musical idea.
它非常极简，但它确实会变得吵闹，也确实会变得安静。无论如何，太阳乐团的一位绅士，你知道的，我不知道他是在夸我，但他只是说，他说，孩子，演出结束后你可真能吼啊。我当时就想，好的，好吧。那些人里有一个觉得我很酷，你知道的。
It's very minimalist, but it does do get loud and it does get quiet. Anyway, but one of the gentlemen from the Sunra Orchestra, you know, I don't know if he was complimenting me But he just said, he said, boy, he said, you sure can holler like that after the show. And I was just like, yeah, it's like, all right. One of those guys thought I was cool, you know.
他基本上是在说，你知道的，吼得好，你知道的，也就是很好地利用了你大嗓门的技巧或者别的什么，你知道的。他可能不一定完全在音乐上理解它，但他懂我们想做什么。所以我非常喜欢这种认可，你知道的，来自一个“猫王”（老手），可以说，来自一个爵士老手，感觉真的棒极了，你知道的。是的，是的。
He was basically saying, you know, good holler, you know, like good utilization of your loud chops or whatever, you know. And he didn't quite get it necessarily, musically, but he got what we were trying to do. And so I like that validation a lot, you know, from a cat, so to speak, from a jazz cat, felt really great, you know. Yeah, yeah.
来自一个不玩你们这种音乐的人，却以这种方式给予认可，一个真正付出了代价的人，我们可以这么说。是的，是的，是的。你知道的，能得到他们的认可或其他什么，我觉得，好吧，好吧，所以也许我们真的在搞什么名堂。这是真的，或者别的什么。它有一种，你知道的，某种魔力或别的什么。
From somebody who doesn't play the kind of music that you guys do to sort of acknowledge it in that way, someone who's truly paid their dues, shall we say. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, to get validation from them or whatever, I felt like, okay, all right, so maybe we're on to like something. It's real or something. It's got some sort of, you know, mojo or whatever.
我们身上发生了一些神奇的事情。它是，我们是特别的，你知道的，我们有些东西。是的，我们很棒。等等，所以现在，但是现在你们付出了代价，你们必须承认现在你们他妈的付出了代价。你们已经出道40年了，基本上你们是在办一个40周年的重聚，不，重聚，我不应该这么说，
We have some sort of magical thing going on. It is, we are special, you know, we have something. Yeah, we're good. Wait, so now, but now you paid your, you got to admit now you paid your fucking dues. You guys are 40 years in, basically you're doing a 40-year reunion, not reunion, I shouldn't say that,
完全不是，你们在办一个第40个，几乎就像是一个周年巡演，如果你愿意的话，今年带着你们的，这是你们的第九张录音室专辑吗？是这样吗，第九张还是第十张？差不多吧。对吧，僵尸来那晚？我不确定这个40周年纪念的角度。
at all, you guys are doing a 40th, kind of almost like an anniversary tour, if you will, this year with your, is it your ninth studio album? Is that right, ninth or 10th? Something like that. Right, the night the zombies came? I'm not sure about this. this 40th anniversary angle.
我觉得……那是我的主意。我跟乔说，如果是50周年，也许我们会想，好吧，我们得承认。我们真的很老了，我们已经干了50年了，管他呢。但40岁感觉有点像，嘘。我们真的需要谈谈这已经持续了多久吗。不。
I feel like... That's me. I was telling Joe that if it was like 50th, maybe we're like, all right, we gotta own it. We're like really old and we've been doing it for 50 years and whatever. But 40 feels a little bit like, shh. We really need to like talk about like how long it's been going on. No.
就谈谈我。你知道的，所以我并不介意你提起它。我只是，我意识到，因为我们不一定能选择那个钩子，你知道的，也许一个宣传人员或某个人正在用它来宣传你们接下来的这轮演出。最近我得知那是40周年纪念。我当时想，
Just like talk about me. You know, so I don't mind you bringing it up. I'm just, I'm realizing, because we don't necessarily choose the hook, you know, that maybe a publicist or somebody is employing to promote your next little run of shows. And recently I learned it was like 40th anniversary. I'm like
他妈的，我40岁了。那才叫周年纪念。是的。这对你的宣传人员来说是个好消息。你的公关团队会让他们在以后的所有资料中删除这个。但你们要巡演。是的，我的意思是，这说得通。我懂。这是个好
fucking, I was 40th. That's an anniversary. Yeah. This is a good note for your publicist right now. Your publicity team will let them know to drop that from all materials going forward. But you guys are going to tour. Yeah, I mean, it makes sense. I get it. It's a good
钩子。我的意思是，你知道的，但管他呢。我想我有点，你知道的，那个词是什么？我想我很虚荣，就是这样。是这样吗？是的，我们也是，老兄。我的意思是，从外表很难想象杰森是虚荣的，但他确实非常虚荣。所以你们，你们，当你们今年进行这次巡演时，我的意思是，你们刚刚结束，听起来几周前才刚有一场演出。
hook. I mean, you know, but whatever. I guess I'm a little, you know, what's the word? I guess I'm Vane is what it is. Is that what it is? Yeah, we are too, man. Yeah. I mean, it's hard to imagine that Jason's vain by looking at him, but he is very vain. And so do you guys, do you guys, when you go out on this tour this year, I mean, you just finished, it sounds like a couple weeks ago, a show.
但当你们去巡演时，有多少，因为你们的创作力太旺盛了，就像我提到的，你们的第九或第十张录音室专辑，你们有多少，在里面穿插多少新歌，我的意思是，你们一定有歌迷在喊，请唱《Here Comes Your Man》，这就像是，你知道的，或者别的什么。就像，你们一定，你们会演奏贯穿你们整个曲库的歌吗？当然，是的。是的，我们通常会排练大概50首歌，然后我们在演出时就现场点歌，你知道的。然后，你知道的，我们大致知道哪些是前十名的歌，我们也知道哪些是我们喜欢演奏、听起来效果很好的歌，我想。我的意思是，我不知道每个人是否都能通过所选的歌单得到满足。但是，你知道的，有很多歌，你知道的，听起来有点平淡或者别的什么，你知道的。你会想，哦，这首歌他们一定会疯狂的。但当你每次都弹它时，就会觉得，也就那样吧。你知道的，所以我认为它总是倾向于……我们只是学一批歌。我们的大脑大概能应付50个曲目。
But when you go out on tour, how much, because you guys are so prolific, like, as I mentioned, your ninth or tenth studio album, how much do you make a, how much do you make, up new stuff with, I mean, you've got to have people going like, please play, here comes your man, which is just like, you know, or whatever. Like, you must have, do you play some of the songs from across your catalog? Sure, yeah. Yeah, we usually rehearse up like 50 songs and then we just call them out, you know, when we play a show. And then, you know, we kind of know which are the top 10 and we know which the ones that
但那已经很多了。好吧，那就他妈的开始巡演吧。顺便问一下，查尔斯，查尔斯，这很多。50首真的很多。乔，你有没有一首你一直很喜欢弹的歌？就像当你开始弹它时，你有没有这样一首？我的意思是，我确信很难缩小范围，但你有没有一首你会全身心投入进去、
we like to play that sound good, I think. I mean, I don't know if everyone gets to scratch their rich with the set list that's chosen. But, you know, there's a lot of songs that, you know, kind of like they fall flat or whatever, you know. You think, oh, that one they're really going to go crazy for it. But then when you do it every time, it's like, it's okay. You know, so I think it always kind of gravitates towards a... We just learn a batch. Our brains can handle about 50 numbers.
进入那种状态并且超级喜欢的歌？这取决于当晚的状态。我确实喜欢弹《Tame》，因为我觉得自己在上面像个傻逼，你知道的。我觉得这首歌从头到尾只有三个和弦，查尔斯。是吗？而我只弹一个。查尔斯，不过在经历了这一切之后，感觉一定很棒吧。
But that's a lot. All right, let's just fucking go on tour. By the way, Charles, Charles, that's a lot. 50 is a lot. Joe, do you have a song that you have always loved to play? Like when you just start to play it, do you have one? I mean, I'm sure it's hard to narrow it down, but do you have one that you kind of get into that,
我提到了《Here Comes Your Man》。我的意思是，那是你写的一首歌。那是你早期的作品，而且它依然保留着这种感觉——再次谈到一首拥有这种持久生命力的歌，它今天听起来依然和你们最初构思它时一样具有现实意义。这一定很有成就感。
into a thing with it and you just love it? It depends on the night. I do like to play tame because I feel like a watch. ass on it, you know. I think the song has three chords the whole time, Charles. Yeah? And I do one. Charles, it must feel good, though, after all.
我最终渐渐喜欢上了这首歌。我想当我们在早期演出曲目中演奏它时，它是那种可能有点偏流行风格的歌，我们不知道它是不是太流行了或者听起来太美好了。但是制作人吉尔（Gil），我们和他合作过两三张专辑，四张专辑。他真的很喜欢那一首，所以它从早期的曲目库中被复活了，
I mentioned, here comes your man. I mean, that was a song that you wrote. That was an early song of yours, and it's still got this, talk about a song again that's just got this kind of staying power, that still feels just as relevant today as the moment you dreamed it up. It must be kind of gratifying.
最终出现在了它登上的那张专辑上，也就是《Doolittle》，我们的第三张专辑。而且我相信在美国发行我们专辑的唱片公司是，他们叫什么名字来着，乔？Elektra唱片公司，他们和演艺圈有着各种各样的联系。我记得那是我们唯一一次做出某种非常文艺腔的、管你屁事、我们不在乎的举动，他们想让我们在哪个节目上演奏那首歌，乔，是哪个？Arsenio Hall秀。Arsenio Hall。
I have grown to like the song eventually. I think that when we played it in our early repertoire, it was one of the ones that were kind of maybe a bit poppy that we didn't know if it was too poppy or too kind of nice sounding. But the producer, Gil, that we did a couple or three records with, four records with. He really liked that one, so it got resurrected from the early repertoire,
我最终还是喜欢上了这首歌。我想在我们早期的曲目里，它可能是那种稍微有点流行风格的歌，我们当时不知道它是不是太流行了，或者听起来是不是有点太好听了。但制作人吉尔——我们和他合作过两三张专辑，四张专辑——他真的很喜欢那一首，所以它从早期的曲目中被复活了，
finally to the record that it showed up on, which was Doolittle, our third record. And I believe that the record company that was distributing our record in the USA was, what were they called, Joe? Electra Records, and they had like all kinds of connections to showbiz. And I remember that was the only time we did some sort of real artsy-fartsy, screw you all, we don't care, move, was they wanted us to play that song on what show, Joe, was it? Arsenio All. Arsiniol.
最后说到收录这首歌的专辑，也就是我们的第三张专辑《Doolittle》。我记得当时在美国发行我们专辑的唱片公司是——乔，他们叫什么名字来着？Elektra唱片公司，他们拥有各种娱乐圈的人脉。我记得那是我们唯一一次搞什么真正的高雅艺术、管你们去死、我们不在乎的把戏，当时他们想让我们在哪档节目里唱那首歌来着，乔？是阿瑟尼奥秀吗？阿瑟尼奥秀。
And that felt like too weird to us to like, oh, that's silly. Like we don't, we, that's our silly song or that's our song that's too, sweet. And maybe it's all, we don't understand, like, it's all going too fast. Like they wants to play in our city hall. And we have to do that song. There's no other song we can do. That's the thing that's going to represent us. We just, I think now we'd be like, oh, awesome, TV, yeah, you know. But at the time, I think there was a little bit of a concern of being, there was a little bit of a too, I didn't have a big, we didn't have a big too cool for school attitude, but, you know, a little bit once in a while. You know, you know, you.
而且我们觉得那太奇怪了，就像，哦，太傻了。就好像我们不，我们，那是我们傻气的歌，或者是我们太甜蜜的歌。也许这一切，我们不理解，就像，这一切发展得太快了。就像他们想在我们的市政厅演出。而我们必须唱那首歌。没有别的歌我们可以唱。那是将代表我们的东西。我们只是，我想现在我们会觉得，哦，太棒了，电视，是的，你知道的。但在当时，我想稍微有点担忧，有点太，我没有一个大，我们没有那种“装酷”的态度，但是，你知道，偶尔还是有一点。你知道，你知道，你。
Yeah. We don't do that, you know. Yeah, we've all been there. So we had that, I feel badly because it wasn't anything against any particular program or whatever. It's just the idea that that feels too mainstream. Too late. Arsenio is mad at you too late. Listen, man, I want to say, what I love about that particular song, I will say,
是的。我们不那样做，你知道。是的，我们都经历过。所以我们有那种感觉，我感到很抱歉，因为这并不是针对任何特定的节目或其他什么。这只是那种感觉太主流了。太迟了。阿瑟尼奥生你的气也太迟了。听着，老兄，我想说，我最喜欢那首歌的特定之处，我要说的是，
that it feels like it could have been written any year from sort of 1950 on. There's something about it to me that just kind of cuts across everything. there's something, I don't know, timeless. So I love that song in particular. That's just me. We play it every show. I enjoy playing it now, and I've tried to gradually appreciate
它感觉就像是从1950年左右开始的任何一年写出来的。它对我来说有一种超越一切的特质。有一种，我不知道，永恒的东西。所以我特别喜欢那首歌。那只是我。我们每场演出都演奏它。我现在很享受演奏它，而且我一直在慢慢欣赏
whatever it is that people are responding to in it. Yeah. Yeah, it's a nice little doo-doo. It's bouncy. Everyone seems to be in a pretty good mood when we play it. And I don't know, my mood seems to pick up a little bit when we play it. There you go.
人们对它产生共鸣的种种原因。是的。是的，这是一首不错的小曲。很有活力。当我们演奏它时，每个人似乎都心情不错。而且我不知道，当我们演奏它时，我的心情似乎也会稍微好一点。就是这样。
That's the most important thing. You know, so that's a good sign. That's good, Charles. Listen, guys, we've dominated your time. I'm just, it's such a thrill both Charles and Joe to have you guys here today. Very nice of you guys to join us. I mean, you guys, your 9th or 10th studio album,
这是最重要的事情。你知道，所以这是个好兆头。很好，查尔斯。听着，伙计们，我们占用了你们很多时间。我只是，查尔斯和乔，能让你们今天来到这里真是太激动了。非常感谢你们能加入我们。我的意思是，你们，你们的第九或第十张录音室专辑，
the night the zombies came is just an absolute testament to your staying power. You guys are on tour this year. Charles, I won't say your 40th reunion tour or anniversary tour at all. I've taken that out. We're just calling it a big. A victory tour.
《今夜僵尸来临》绝对是对你们持久影响力的证明。你们今年在巡演。查尔斯，我绝不会把它称为你们的四十周年重聚巡演或周年纪念巡演。我已经把那句话去掉了。我们只管它叫一场盛大的。胜利巡演。
Rebirth. By the way, Charles, I think next year, if you don't mind being paid by rubies instead of currency. Yeah, there you go. 40th anniversary is the ruby. It's the ruby. Is that bothering? No money.
重生。顺便说一句，查尔斯，我想明年，如果你不介意用红宝石而不是货币来获得报酬的话。是的，就是这样。四十周年是红宝石。是红宝石。这让人烦恼吗？没有钱。
Just a wedding anniversary is a ruby. So it's ruby. Oh, it's like stones. Yeah, we're going to be paid by ruby. Yeah, we got a guy in Antwerp who's going to be mulling some rubies to you, Charles, so it's all good, man. What a thrill. You guys, unbelievable, continued success.
结婚周年纪念日才是红宝石。所以这是红宝石。哦，就像石头一样。是的，我们要用红宝石获得报酬。是的，我们在安特卫普有一个人会给你运送一些红宝石，查尔斯，所以一切都好，老兄。真是令人兴奋。你们，难以置信，持续的成功。
You brought so much joy and so much, just amazing music to people over the years. And I'm such a fan, and I just thank you for your time, honestly. Thank you so much. Thank you for all the kind words, and thank you for having us on. Thanks for being here, guys. All right, Pixies, everybody.
多年来，你们给人们带来了如此多的快乐，如此多，如此美妙的音乐。我是你们的超级粉丝，我真的非常感谢你们抽出时间。非常感谢。谢谢你们所有的赞美，也谢谢邀请我们来。谢谢你们来到这里，伙计们。好的，各位，这就是Pixies乐队。
Thank you, guys. Bye, gentlemen. Adios. Thank you. Adios. Bye. Bye. Guys.
谢谢你们，伙计们。再见，先生们。再见。谢谢。再见。再见。再见。伙计们。
That was pretty amazing. Yeah. That's, what a three. for me to have things on. I love that. Yeah, I remember in college, you know, I think they started in mid-80s and in college. You were on the, you were here for when we were talking to them, right? But I mean, specifically, it was like 85 or 86 or something like that.
这真是太棒了。是的。真是，对我来说能有这些东西。我喜欢那样。是的，我记得在大学里，你知道，我想他们在80年代中期开始，在大学里。当我们在和他们交谈时，你就在这里，对吧？但我的意思是，具体来说，就像85年或86年左右。
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, and I went to college in 88 and they, yeah, they were big on campus. I mean, I, I listened, I heard some other songs, and I know a couple other songs, but I didn't know, you know, anything about them until today. so it's really cool. I think I wore a T-shirt of theirs in something. A lot of people had their T-shirts for some reason. I remember seeing T-shirts.
是的，是的。是的，我88年上大学，他们，是的，他们在校园里很受欢迎。我的意思是，我，我听过，我听过一些其他的歌，我也知道其他几首歌，但在今天之前我对他们一无所知。所以这真的很酷。我想我在某些场合穿过他们的T恤衫。不知为什么，很多人都有他们的T恤。我记得见过T恤。
And I think on the back it said Audios. Or was that a Sonic Youth shirt? And when you just said Adiosia at the end. I was like, you know, you'd see somebody wearing like a Pixie's T-shirt. You'd be like, all right, this person knows what's up. Yeah, that's cool. Unless it was J.B., of course.
我想背面写着“Adios”。还是那是Sonic Youth乐队的T恤？当你刚才在最后说“Adiosia”时。我就觉得，你知道，你会看到有人穿着Pixies的T恤。你会觉得，好吧，这个人很懂行。是的，这很酷。当然，除非那是J.B.穿的。
Yeah, just playing a character that's cool. Yeah. Right, right, right. All right. I would love you to play a cool character once. Didn't you wear a pixie's shirt and black, Black Rabbit? Yeah, that's, yes, that's what I'm talking about, yeah. And I took it, I took it.
是的，只是扮演一个很酷的角色。是的。对，对，对，对。好吧。我很想让你扮演一次酷角色。你不是在《黑兔子》里穿了一件Pixies的T恤吗？是的，那是，是的，这就是我所说的，是的。我拿了，我拿了。
I was like, hey, can I have this when we finished? Because I want to be cool at home. I want to be cool, dad. You have a pixies shirt at home? Oh, yeah, a couple of them. Let me come over and bring you some soup. Would you please? Yep.
我当时想，嘿，我们结束时我能拿走这个吗？因为我想在家里装酷。我想装酷，爸爸。你家里有一件Pixies的T恤？哦，是的，有好几件。让我过来给你带点汤吧。行吗？行。
I'm sick, man. It's not to steal your pixies shirt, okay? It's not to. Come on, but we can just try on a bunch of stuff, you know? No, we're not doing like a try. and put some stuff on you and just dress you up a little bit what do you talk some photos do a smear some lipstick on me i'd love to put you in a bunch of my clothes wouldn't that be fun if i just come over and i just put you in a bunch of my clothes oh my god that sounds so creepy silence of the
我病了，老兄。不是为了偷你的PixiesT恤，好吗？不是为了这个。拜托，但我们只是一起试穿一堆衣服，你知道吗？不，我们不是在做试穿。然后给你穿上一些衣服，稍微给你打扮一下，你在说什么拍几张照片，在我脸上抹点口红，我很乐意给你穿上一堆我的衣服，如果我过来然后给你穿上一堆我的衣服，那不是很有趣吗？天哪，听起来太毛骨悚然了，《沉默的
lambs oh i'd have to see you in this oh yeah that reminds me of sandra burnhard and uh king of comedy she starts knitting him a sweater when she's got them all tied up i'd love to see in this you think the sleeves are too short. Anyway. I haven't seen that in a long time. Do you remember that... Oh, here we go. Do you remember that song?
羔羊》哦，我得看你穿这个的样子，哦，是的，这让我想起桑德拉·伯恩哈德在《喜剧之王》里，当她把他们都绑起来时，她开始给他织一件毛衣。我很想看你穿这个的样子，你觉得袖子太短了吗？总之。我好久没看过那部电影了。你还记得那首……哦，开始了。你还记得那首歌吗？
Oh, he's got his hands on one. I can see. It's the twinkle in his eye. Well, they mentioned Modern Love by David Bowie, and I was thinking about those lyrics of Modern Love. Never wave.
哦，他手里拿了一个。我能看出来。他眼里闪烁着光芒。好吧，他们提到了大卫·鲍伊的《现代爱情》，我想到了《现代爱情》的那些歌词。永不挥手。
Yeah, I'm standing in the wind, but I never wave. Bye, bye. Bye. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbico. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，我站在风中，但我从不挥手。拜拜。拜拜。Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴尔比科100%有机手工打造。Smartless。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。